[Applause]
shredder's ready to attack
wow what a night
[Music]
hard times that kid actually got an ear
infection
and it's like since you started
preschool he's sick every day bro it's
like the worst thing ever something new
that's probably where i got the rash
from one of those little freaks out of
school
you know what i'm saying
think about that all right
look how huge my hands look today
after that surgery
so small that's
today's epi we have such a freaking good
episode today
we have probably the most fun things
planned all episode long all right thank
you to mint mobile hellofresh and honey
let me lay things out for you here today
semen
fan favorite
that's what i said
the letter
semen tastes good right just making sure
that's what i'm saying i don't
understand what you're talking about
semen it sounded like you said semen
that is what i said
what's the difference between the two
things you said
semen is is another kind of milk so
siemens calling him
and we've prepared a segment for your
boy first of all we need to apologize to
him because
we found out that um what was his name
the kid liam liam bless him you know
he he trolled he did troll
trolling we all got full well not all of
us but
there was it was hotly debated you know
no shame to anyone that got got on that
one well as i was saying before last
week but i got got because because well
seaman
he like made the whole thing so
confusing because he said he talked to
him yeah all right
like
if he didn't say that we would have all
known he was trolling yeah
but anyway we've prepared an apolog
apologetory
segment for him
where we have prepared feet picks of all
of us yes that's right dick's out boys
we've got a special feat pics of all of
us except dan who is protesting he
doesn't want to show his feed
dan's the only one actually sorry
there's one more right missing
wait someone else artist shell
is it sam yeah oh sam didn't show feed
that's fine
and i and i get that you know it's not
everyone's comfortable with that i mean
for example you know you usually have to
pay for that kind of thing and i get
that
dan's holding up get it for free today
i took a page from bel delphine how you
know yeah she held out for years on
doing the porn thing yeah i'll show feed
eventually don't give it away for free
when i'm down enough gnarlier the better
it makes me comfy now when i hear it
um yeah so we've prepared all of our
have made a beautiful feed spread we're
going to present them to him anonymously
make a tear list and then reveal the
foot to him and we will find out from
the foot connoisseur himself who among
us has the best feet
by the way did we ever get the one from
the x factor we had one for my x factor
do we ever get that zach x factor let me
know what i'm talking let me follow up
with that
what
we do have okay good nice that's
exciting
okay that's and then like dude we've got
uh
actually right at the top here you know
we were working on um
we were talking about how i was going to
get the
lengthening surgery you know you
remember that
and i've been looking into it quite a
bit you have
so here's the deal i i went we've been
talking a lot about this there's a
procedure where you can lengthen how
tall you are up to
six inches
that's enormous
yeah i'd be six five if i did this
yeah so and it costs 150 000
so you know
i've been really considering it
here's a little summary and i think i'm
gonna do it i actually think you know
you can permanently get taller 12.
i want to explain to you guys a little
bit about
a little bit of bone drilling i make
small little tiny incisions tiny little
scissors and on your hips and then we
put this nail which is called the
precise nail now this is a self
lengthening nail however it is
controlled with it it means what it
means once it's inserted inside the leg
and this now has a magic insert this is
a magic nail we cut
and over time this bone will harden and
become a permanent part of your body yes
so anyway i've done enough research i've
decided i'm going for the procedure
so
you know what ian
let's just roll it
the good looking guy but has always
wanted to be taller now he's getting his
chance thanks to groundbreaking limb
lengthening surgery why are you watching
this again this is this thing is
disturbing don't you think it's
inspiring that like he's a good looking
guy but if he was taller he'd be it
probably it'd be a 10.
he's like a little munchkin but if he
was 6'5 or something
5'7 is not even that short five seven
you know we've been joking about this
but i'm kind of
interested i'm not short i'm not short
but if i could go from like 5 11
to
you know six five i'd be like ready for
the end i think that i i don't think
they can even do that much that's dude
just imagine hassan six four people
would be thrift strapping me all day if
i was six five my views would double job
security for life bro still though i
don't think that's healthy you know
everything comes out of cost obviously
uh when you do this i don't think you
can walk for like a year
yeah i mean i sit for the show so i
don't anticipate that being a problem
anyway listen uh
actually i need to take off i have a
thing i got it you're not going to go
get the surgery are you
no of course not
it's got a thing i got to do
don't get the surgery no i'm not getting
the surgery don't worry don't get the
surgery stop i'm not leave me alone
he's going to get that [ __ ] surgery
daddy's home
i got some new legs boys
hell yeah i did it i got the surgery i'm
8-2 now i'm i'm the tallest man that's
ever lived you're not supposed to be
walking
they said i have to wait a year but who
[ __ ] wait in a year i mean i can
barely walk but that's fine right you
get the penile enlargement too or just
penile enlargements next week at 8-2 my
dick was smaller but now compared to my
height it's like way out of control so
the doctor said we can make the penis to
match and also enlarge that come sit
next to me what are you 6'3
yeah come here what's up short stuff
how's the weather down there
oh stop it you're tall go sit down
anyway guys get back to work i think
your knees are bending backwards yeah
well there are obviously some
complications it's a it's a it's a
dramatic surgery it takes my body some
getting used to it
blood on the ground damn stop stop stop
this is the new me okay come on let's go
all right
can someone give me a hand actually i
can't walk unassisted
there we go
i had to get these jeans custom-made
actually
the big boy store
it just doesn't cover you when you're
eight two you know what i'm saying dude
how tall are you you ever shopped in
that in the 4xl shop cameron hey they
don't fit me not even close you're
walking like a baby goat oh stop you're
bitter you're jealous what you looking
for buddy
holy [ __ ] nothing i i got it
don't don't spray yourself what do you
need i mean it's right here
i don't know if you can hear me from
there maybe let's train yourself it's
okay i got it i'm eight two now here's
the paper towels thank you good okay
thank you you're welcome oh actually i
need your help i can't reach the bottom
drawer can you get me one of the uh
snack packs out there on the bottom
this yeah that's good thank you buddy
and actually i can't reach the forks
either
thanks bro no problem i got you you're
welcome thank you
yeah i got your [ __ ] beanie dude
try to grab it
try to grab it i'm not gonna do that try
to grab it it's so high you just give me
my beanie bag you're a little manly bro
buddy how tall are you like five nine
what the [ __ ] dude come on
make me fall
manly
manly
manly
oh yeah
don't push me bro you'll kill me must
suck to be only five what are you five
seven five five
four nine i'm six foot
what's up bro you forget on me too
i got an eye on everything what are you
guys working on jesus just prepping for
the show
is it cold down there or is it just up
here
wow are you asking that well i just
figured that there would probably be a
temperature difference you know up here
at eight foot two temperature's fine
down here yeah only a couple feet
difference okay we'll go ahead i'm just
gonna survey the land zach what are you
working on uh mixing uh for off the
rails can you turn it up because i just
feel like the sound doesn't travel so
far up you probably need to crank
it uh
turn it upside down a
decent level but i don't hear anything
[Music]
i can't hear it you got to turn it up
for me
actually really
what are we gonna do without men who are
eight foot two okay zach six three he's
bitter and my [ __ ] ears are bleeding
right now
your guys are such bitter haters can you
is there something can you go help down
with something or okay but i'm i'm gonna
hit the ac on the way out it's actually
kind of warm to be honest okay i'm just
gonna turn it down because you know heat
travels upwards yeah can you get that
vent actually you know that we've been
trying to fix that for months oh yeah i
can reach that thank you it's actually
it's actually up and away
yeah yeah it's right there yeah damn
ethan it looks like you
you're not tall enough buddy i don't
think you're going to reach it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you're 6'3 who are you laughing at
you little manlet you can't get it
help me you guys
i took it too far
too far
guys
help
help me guys seriously help me
dan
oh my god
olivia it's still me
i'm still ethan i'm your boss oh god i'm
still me i just took it too far evil i'm
the same man i'm just [ __ ] cursed
dude nobody got gasoline i wanted to get
the vent
i wanted to be too tall
somebody held me you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah well
this is all i've got for legs now
my dream has turned into a nightmare
the good news is i'm 30 feet tall by far
the tallest man you can't stand though i
my legs are basically liquid liquefied
[Music]
it's just i can't i can't stand i'm i'm
actually gonna have to get probably
these um
amputated try some
oh
[ __ ]
at least you got a big pecker now
yeah we did that we cancelled that too
because oh apparently i had too much
blood loss and if i get like a boner
i'll go like i'll pass out because i
just don't have enough blood in my body
and it's not and you know that's not
saying anything
[ __ ] dude
so that's it
my dream has become a nightmare but uh
good job everyone
thank you everyone for your support on
the matter
absolutely
yeah
somebody just popped in okay so so
speaking of gabe
my clock gave here he just had his 50th
birthday party yesterday gabe
first of all happy birthday i need to
ask you what is your secret to youth
because you are the best looking 50 year
old i have ever met
oh
yeah i know
just felt hung over from last night
yeah is it white claw is that the the
secret to youth
probably
baby [ __ ] can i see your hat
sure
oh [ __ ] you got like a blinged out white
claw gabe i know
did someone make that for you
something like that
sam made it sam sam
appreciate the love my real fans you're
my real friends we are you were your
family bro
yeah
you really feel that bad huh how much
you drink last night
i had like
like three three tequilas and probably
two or three um vodkas kind of like in
the mix
wow
spinning last night it's uh i looked
like you had a really fun time though
all the guys from the crew were there i
saw you you had a stripper
i saw all that dude
a big booty stripper huh
that was awesome
yeah you guys were i saw i saw a lot of
gabe getting very close and personal
with that stripper
you make any moves on her later in the
night or not like in a weird way but you
know
probably just touching and stuff hell
yeah
oh yeah
[ __ ]
well dude
wow i it looks like you're you're
suffering there a little bit i'll let
you get back to it but we just wanted to
wish you a happy birthday and also well
also what's
tomorrow ooh saturday
saturday
my favorite day of the week
all right baby
is there school or work tomorrow nope no
school or work tomorrow [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
stay
[ __ ]
yeah we got you to cheer up a little bit
there with uh
friday
[Music]
all right man
well
we appreciate you have a good birthday
out there okay buddy thanks all right
you take care you birthday you do good
have a good day yeah you too bud damn
[Music]
well
you know
so there's a bunch of um
footage from that birthday yeah so this
is insane um
yesterday was white club gabe's 50th
birthday
and the whole crew went there and you
guys kind of got trashed you went got
fully immersed like uh
who the who there last night was
drinking by the way
it was uh me and ian
oh okay
yeah
you guys like close that [ __ ] out too
huh
like i saw when you guys were filming
everybody was gone
this was initially supposed to be part
of the behind the scenes but it was so
good we figured would include some of it
uh to show everyone else as well oh my
god that's a good sale for our but
behind the scenes shout out to our
members who are getting another behind
the scenes this week right av it's ready
right now yeah i just gotta upload it
after the episode dude i'm telling you
there's some good stuff in this bts you
don't want to miss so thank you to our
members
for making it all happen
before we get into that actually i do
want to shout out teddy fresh thank you
shout out to ela she's worked her butt
off on this looney tunes teddy fresh
collab i'm wearing the
dress
you want to show off the dress
boom boom boom that's actually well
overall
check it out
i'm wearing the color block hoodie
actually what's really nice is that the
inside has like a flat plaid lining
you know
we got the bomber jacket we got the
hoodies we got
the blueprint the comics
the jeans hassan wanted all the um
the women's clothing we were showing him
stuff he's like i want the jeans we're
like it's women's
and then the other thing he wanted was
the turtleneck oh we're like you could
you look cute
but um
all praise eela
on another beautiful collection head
over teddyfresh.com check it out
[Applause]
this one's a personal favorite of mine
oh man that one's sold out cool
the dark one is gone
i'm surprised that sometimes i'm more
surprised by the colors that are popular
like i get people like the dark wearable
colors more but
i thought this one would
would do better there you go your mom is
calling me my mom go ahead take a butter
on speaker everyone loves that [ __ ]
you know
um
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
mom
okay
mom
you're live on the show
just to warn you
dad and i are going to the movies and
then we're gonna we'll be back in a
couple hours we're gonna
don't say anything about our plans
tonight on live air please thank you
okay
but ethan that's why i'm calling
well you know we're live
you can't talk to us about that right
now
i don't want people to know what we're
doing
oh you're both on the show live oh god
it's friday it's friday baby friday baby
well we'll call you when we're done
okay okay
all right bye bye
my mom's about to like dox the hell out
of us
she's like here's what will be at our
specific time and location
all right well
um so where's the footage here this this
it's in vmix too we can play it okay
yeah so this is off the rail this is
just off the rails you didn't show how
much of the stripper's stuff did not
you can show whatever you want because
if it goes yellow it doesn't matter at
all true
spice even for the members i don't know
no you could show the stripper no she's
not naked she's just in a thong yeah it
was like pg it's just a lot of ass
i think for the members go all out
that's what it's all about let's do it
so members
you're going to get to see not only
why claw gabe give a get a lap dance but
also give a lot that's right it's off
the rails completely that's right
that's right that's right all right so
so go ahead with it baby a little
preview
just another saturday baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fried chicken wednesday [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
get a shot of this right here look at
this oh [ __ ] egg baby
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you're keeping it a secret
yeah that looked like a crazy
fried chicken fried chicken
strippers
that's a birthday party
apparently he was he was loving lena
he loved it was that right yeah he
really liked lina it was very sweet
yeah his family was very nice everyone
was so friendly what a razor dude
everyone was i mean super nice the
spread was insane the food spread so
what kind of food it was like the the
fried chicken obviously chicken
mcnuggets mcdonald's donuts oh [ __ ] egg
mcdonald's
i like that they just had the eggos in
the waffle cued up yeah
that's like the best party i've seen yes
and a lot of
people his family was so awesome
it was so fun
was it weird with the stripper just
because
no it was no sam and
yeah does she have a big instagram
following
she has like
almost ten thousand i think okay yeah
she was awesome deja what's up
shout out to deja vu
yeah it was great i didn't know you
could touch strippers like i mean it's
not like he was being a creep but like
he had his hands on her ass and stuff
like she like
guy did yeah yeah no i'm not i i know it
was all good i just was like i guess
i just always thought you couldn't touch
but gabe makes his own rules because
he's got that swag
we were taking like back-to-back shots
with him too oh my god that was pretty
insane
i mean he's like i'm gonna i'm not
stopping to like puke [ __ ]
he's such a legend and his whole family
is just so amazing there it is shout out
to nick we'd be next to gabe and it'd
just be quiet for a little bit just a
little awkward moment and then you'd
just go
[Music]
yeah he was talking with the stripper
and she leaned down because she didn't
hear what he said and when she leaned
down he went
oh my god that's just the greatest
wow and then we were when we were taking
pictures you'd only do three poses it
was peace sign
and then the last one was middle finger
like he took that same pose with
everybody at the park polar opposites
peace and [ __ ]
at one point he like turned over looked
at me dead in the eye and he goes did
someone [ __ ] say there's molly in
this [ __ ]
what i don't know if he was just doing
the character but it was hilarious
oh my god white claw gay was ready to
drop molly i can confirm there was no
molly though at least to my knowledge it
was good friendly fun
uh he looked pretty hungover
you guys are not as hungover as he yeah
definitely this morning i was kind of
sucking [ __ ] but
advil definitely helps
i am shocked that it is 50.
dude that's the beginning i thought he
would be like i don't know 38
that was like that oldest you know i had
oldest
i mean 50 years old my goodness gabe
what have you doing with you i got to
live like he does i think i am though i
think i do live like he does
and i don't look that good
i look older than gabe i'll just say it
yeah
if he's 14 years older we need to uh
start slamming white claws on the
regular that's
keeps you young
[ __ ]
okay so let's let's push on though shout
out happy birthday to white club gabe
we're almost at break time
and after the break we should do the
c-man thing so if you got like a short
little goof well we can go to the
bathroom or wait what is this
some beautiful [ __ ] posting the mcgregor
one or the bathroom pole
um
let's uh let's hold off on the bathroom
pole for a little bit because um a lot
of people are voting right now i was
encouraging them in the chat okay so
guys get your votes in on who had the
best bathroom
from our previous episode we make custom
bathrooms and we're gonna i'm gonna try
to make whatever whoever's the winner
so there's an important tip here about
brushing your teeth
that i'm actually going to try um
it says ethan your brushing technique is
inferior what the [ __ ] can you say that
to me
you say you don't rinse your mouth after
brushing but that means that because
that the bacteria still stays in your
mouth oh my god you don't understand
hold on
you should rinse then lightly brush with
little toothpaste after oh my god that
sounds good to me i have no cavities why
don't you talk to someone that actually
has bro
you're annoying perfect gums perfect
teeth you want to give you want to give
up meditation tips to siddhartha yeah
get the [ __ ] out of
here but i'm going to try them
i'll be honest with you guys i actually
don't leave the toothpaste to me i don't
i started doing that i do it sometimes
it's too grimy
i know you're supposed to because when i
uh went to the dentist last time i was
like what do you recommend for
toothpaste and she was like
it doesn't matter as long as you just
keep it and you don't rinse afterwards
like the best toothpaste is the one that
you keep in your mouth oh really that's
what she said things i brush for long
enough that i think it doesn't matter
i don't know i mean yeah no arguing with
you you're fine yeah i'm teeth god
hairline and teeth god
but i have um
i've always had uh canker sores in my
mouth
and i also have receding
gums so
they always tell me to use the sensodyne
but the sensodyne toothpaste
gives me canker sores dude the sensitive
toothpaste is the worst [ __ ] i've ever
used whenever i use it my entire mouth
peels so it gives me cancer every time i
use it
it's the worst uh anyone i uh yeah i've
experienced that you mean peels like the
inside oh like my gums of my mouth
literally peel yeah like dead skin
it's like
horrid oh my god don't use that it's not
sensitive but there's nothing sensitive
about it jesus
should be called mouth napalm
so yeah you're not supposed to rinse
your mouth after
all right well
um here's the most beautiful [ __ ] post
we've ever seen i actually agree with
this
we'll do this before the break
these editors man take these memes so
far
it's like this whole
mcgregor
the odyssey of him beating up fans and
different clips i mean it's an editing
masterpiece it really is
it's phenomenal it's like oscar worthy
here uh here don't melt your kid
never speak about me ever in your life
watch yourself a little bit because
you'll be over here quick let me take my
picture
yes so
like there's a kangaroo or something
that hits her and they've just taken all
these unbelievable clips
it's crazy bro and then
it's too slow
[Music]
again
ah
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell
[Music]
are you sure
i used to drag here back in high school
conor mcgregor exactly a quarter mile
away from here
on green i'm going for
how long does it take the rotoscope all
this [ __ ]
i mean
[Music]
that's awesome
[Music]
steal floyd mayweather's hat i'll let
you guys know how it goes
let me call y'all come on make it happen
i'm gonna own one night got your hat
gotcha
[Laughter]
okay
get some help out here
[Applause]
oh i didn't even see this part oh i
didn't see this either
it doesn't make sense if they can edit
this game
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah so this guy
vidgeon
[Applause]
and i don't know what the hell else this
guy's up to but i'm sure it's amazing i
looked through his channel it's a lot of
similar stuff that seems to be his
masterpiece though like most of them are
significantly shorter than that that one
is uh
that's an odyssey
yeah so shout outs to him that was just
a pure pure amazing
all right all right we should do the ads
and i'll uh while you're doing that i
will try and queue up uh mr seaman here
yeah this is by the way is this me
someone noticed this guy looks like me
what do you think this post is
unbelievable dude and you're holding
alfredo yeah um
i'm breastfeeding alfredo actually even
more accurate this is from a photography
book from the 70s or something really
yeah
i don't like it
in fact you might say it i hate it it's
almost 2 000
wait only three hours oh god
oh is this the screen wait yeah this was
just posted
we just said three hours 2 000 points no
don't do this to me
some mysteries will never be solved
indeed indeed
well he's skinnier than i am to everyone
saying there's no way that's not ethan
so
i bet if you saw him from a different
angle he wouldn't look anything like me
right
yeah but i think
in this angle i can see what they're
seeing
honestly he's probably better looking
than me he's got a better beard
he's got a better chin
he's skinnier
he's got a little bit of receding here
let's hope check to me on that
you know
god i'm disgusting
i am disgusting it's not a bad picture
why do you hate it so much
it's just weird the doppelganger yeah it
is weird i hate whenever they post
people who look like me yeah because
it's always like uncanny freaky and like
you're like that's not as attractive as
i am it's not it's always like someone
uglier than you perceive yourself to be
everybody says i look like teen mom
teen mom
[Music]
is that a person a girl who was on teen
mom what's her name let's look it up i
actually don't know her name
that's i know the first name is chelsea
that chelsea chelsea chelsea from team
and they specify like chelsea from teen
mom i totally see it
but people comment and they specify are
you ready earlier seasons
are they like no no no back so is this
her
yes that's her but that's her like now
okay so we're talking early seasons
chelsea teen mom
i mean i i guess i
no that's the thing i see
do you see it
okay wait so so we talking like season
one team mom season one we talking early
you know
i think do you see the second photo
where's the left leg
that's what they're talking about i'm
pretty sure [ __ ] that haircut
i mean okay let's be honest it's not a
flattering comparison yeah you're you
know but like i think there's some notes
you can agree we're hitting yeah there's
some and yeah i've swallowed that yeah
yeah and that's you know but
yeah
yo is this her husband
he's a thin blue line babe oh no this is
your future
what do you mean he's got a thin blue
line shirt on
oh yeah
it's like
it's like a police he sims for the
police oh
yeah
it's like a police lives matter thing
it's kind of hunk though dude
all right
we need to gather like unflattering
doppelgangers
i think that'd be interesting
all right well let's do a quick break
and then when we come back we're going
to hit him with our with our hotly
anticipated semen segment
uh so let's just get right into it hey
dan
yes sir and let's start by thinking mint
mint mobile the holiday seasons the best
deal is wireless
let me start over
this holiday season the best deal in
wireless can only be found at mint
mobile right now when you switch to mint
mobile and buy any three month plan
you'll get another
i'm listening to the music just sounds
like static
i can change
there was some metal i was just hearing
like
just because we're hearing it so low
yeah yeah yeah i'll give you a different
turn give me something
okay
we're vibing
right now when you switch to mint mobile
and buy any three month plan you'll get
another three months for free
as the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only mint mobile
let you order from home and save a ton
with a phone plan starting at just
fifteen dollars a month i've been using
mint mobile well dan actually i've tried
mint mobile loved it it's the same as it
always is dan's been using mint mobile
um long before the holiday deal that's
right and um
what do you think dan
it's great it's
it's cell phone service it works it's
the same [ __ ]
but it's cheap
15 a month it's the same [ __ ] as all
these big name brands whatever that you
pay 100 plus a month they literally even
use the same network like look listen to
this
all plants come with unlimited talk and
text plus high speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5g network boom
same [ __ ] just 15 a month
mobile's best offer of the years here
for a limited time by any three month
plan and get three months for free by
doing online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mipmobile
passes significant savings on to you
with mint mobile choose the amount of
monthly data that's right for you and
stop paying for data that you never use
use your own phone with any mobile plan
and keep your same phone number along
with all your existing contacts switch
to main mobile and get premium wireless
service starting at just
15 bucks a month in for a limited time
only buy any three month mint mobile
plan and get three months for free by
going to midmobile.com h3 that's mint
mobile.com
h3 cut your wireless build at 15 bucks a
month mmobill.com
thank you
[Music]
eight all right
hello fresh
i gotta save
hellofresh quickly becoming a favorite
of the super trooper gang
constantly getting beautiful photos from
discord
of people's beautiful home-cooked meals
using hellofresh that looks great it
looks beautiful is that eggplant or like
gnocchi what is that i think it's
scallops
oh [ __ ] olives whoa
that's even fancier than i thought
here's the deal with hellofresh
they're gonna send you a box
with dry ice
perfectly portioned fresh ingredients to
cook a perfect home-cooked meal
you don't want to go grocery shopping
you don't want to buy 10 pounds of
carrots just because you need like half
of one carrot stick you know
you're actually going to save money and
you're going to get better ingredients i
also like hellofresh because i actually
learn a lot about cooking every time i
use it if you're not like an experienced
chef it's a great fun new way to do it
oh abe is this something you cooked yes
oh the av redemption art from the
burrito
go ahead okay
oh [ __ ] bro we often make fun of a bee
here because he did
was just a burrito
but wow this is a redemption moment what
is this zatar cheese that's our
encrusted cheese yeah it's really good
whoa
i want to eat that saute crusted cheese
hold the freaking phone
damn
the holidays can be hectic but hello
fresh keeps things simple with recipes
and ingredients that cut out grocery
shopping and limit meal time prep so you
can spend more time on the festival
season with friends and family hella
fresh offers 50 manual market items to
choose from every week including
vegetarian calorie smart and gourmet
options providing plenty of variety so
if you want to get on board go to
hellofresh.com after dark 14 and use
code after dark 14 for up to 14 free
meals
and three free gifts
once again hellofresh.com slash after
dark 14 and use code after dark 14 for
up to 14 free meals
and there's a reason hello fresh is
america's number one meal kit and we
love them for that so thank you thank
you
that looks great maybe i might even
front like it was really good
just straight up fried cheese like i
didn't even know you could eat that for
a meal but i love that
the zottar
is that baby so what does that mean
exactly
it's like a spice yeah no but okay so
what kind of cheese was it
it was this is not even the out i'm just
curious
i'm just hungry
okay we gotta here we go i'm not sure
we're on a time budget here because
c-man is coming through here so
okay one more one more thank you to
honey hey
we all shop online oh yeah and we all
love to save money
oh yeah we've all been taunted by that
promo code at checkout
oh yeah thanks to honey manual searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your card
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
ranging from tech gaming products
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite sites when the checkout
comes the honey button drops down and
all you have to do is click apply coupon
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site if
honey finds a working coupon you watch
the price drop magically you'll explain
what we're looking at
um here you can see rugs usa i think i
was shopping rugs for the house
and um i wasn't expecting anything but
then honey comes up with some stuff and
it's like hey why not
that's the thing you know and i
genuinely just
love this product because it's like free
money you just don't expect to make yeah
you don't even have to think about it
dude right crowder is all about it
there's a reason honey has founded 17
million members over two billion dollars
add that to the pile if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out on free savings literally
free installs in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this podcast we
love honey i use it myself uh get honey
for free at jointhoney.com
h3ad that's joinhoney.com
h3ad
all right
nice to have good sponsors you like them
all you know they're all solid
i have c-man on standby all right oh
[ __ ] okay we've been we've been working
we've been prepping
saving for this moment so where's the
tier list here bring him up when he's
ready
uh where do i access that tier list it's
in the dock
okay let me go to my spot we can't dilly
dally here seaman is on a
he's on a a
tight deadline here
wait i see the album
okay here we go c-man tier list
so
we have here the tier list for semen
yeah are you working on that dan to
bring him up yep okay great
okay
now we have one pick of everyone's foot
now the idea is once again to present
these anonymously to him
i think we might uh have him i'm here
i'm here hold on hold on
the legend
how you doing what's going on all right
seaman obviously first of all we have to
and an apology to issue
you know did you see liam's video
yes i did and i just thought that you
know it was nice that he finally
contacted me via email and i told him
you know what you did was really wrong
and
he just took it like like it's a big
[ __ ] joke and i'm like you know you
probably damaged tons of guys like us
around the world and it made us look
like fools and if that was intended i
said that's disgusting and he probably
knows i said you even just you you
embarrassed the h3 crew i said because
you know getting on here with a fake
thing is disgusting and
and just to read someone's integrity or
any reputation no matter what business
it is
it's disgusting right well let's look at
it you know the the the silver lining of
course is that it's brought us together
in a meaningful way no i think so too
like i said i i'm very strong and i
think it's great to fight but i think
sometimes you know when people realize
stuff you know that's right and i kind
of thought you guys were trying to think
i was the bad one in that but i know
that most of society out there knows i
was the right one because you know this
all the evidence just was completely
weak well let me let me say just before
we move on to the segment we've planned
for you um great you were saying that
you talked to him that was what was so
confusing for us
i don't know his name but someone
sounded young and was asking me about
stuff like that so he i don't know if he
even gave me his name but why i spoke to
an eighteen-year-old who sucks and he
wants to be what a weird coincidence
because sometimes when they call me up
on the phone and he was off the phones
i'm thinking he spoke to me but now
probably never gave me his real name he
probably used to [ __ ] me that's what i
was thinking so so liam um
you get into any any
interesting uh or sorry seaman
you get into any interesting foot
parties or anything lately
no i'm trying to organize one hopefully
for march or april next year sometimes
somewhere in new york i'm thinking
locations because i'm hoping to uh
probably do some long island suffolk
counties a lot of room out in new
hampshire state park or here in new york
city by the west side highway what
happens at these parties how many people
are we talking about no the thing is it
used to be back in the day they were at
a bar and they tried to fit like a lot
of i think it was about 6 700 guys in a
ball
if we can get a warehouse because no
london england had a warehouse and they
had guys with the mattresses around but
i think if i go back to the house for
the night and get like kegs of beer and
stuff and then i had some kid tell me i
love your idea but let's get some pot
you know i'm very i'm left in many ways
but i'm more neutral i just don't really
want to bring drugs and [ __ ] to stuff
because if things happen i think we
should just enjoy we love have drinks
have a good time but when you start
doing other stuff violence happens oh my
goodness violence at a foot at a foot
wise i'm saying there never was violence
at a footpath i got to say but you know
you got to be careful if you start
bringing out i'm too much you know hard
let me ask you um so you've got 600 men
all foot fetishes right all foot lovers
you guys want to get the feet i wanted
oh guys so what happens there like what
happens you start to drink a little bit
you loosen up what goes down
there's a bar on the west side highway i
remember it was off like the west side i
think off two or three streets um under
14th street in manhattan it was like a
biker bar and they were nice to give the
guy who organized it you know was really
cool to make ten dollars walking in the
bar and the bartenders you know would
give tabs and stuff was a really fun
happy thing and then back then they had
these little little side rooms that were
dark and you know you played people's
feet like 80 guys or just only one guy's
first pretty wild and then they had like
little metal chairs they look like
little beds without things almost like a
little desk chamber and just plain
people's food is pretty wild stuff oh my
goodness that is yeah
it's like disneyland for the people
and i mean if we could do something fun
like try to find a warehouse that's got
enough room to just get people just
there to have fun different roles like
master and slave some people dress up
like policemen environment i mean
there's so much can i ask you so at this
bar are dicks out or dicks in the pants
or out of the men i just remember
playing with street i don't know you
don't remember dicks out of the pants
some guys might have wanted to but what
they did his own business i was just
there for the feed yeah good for you
okay i had to ask
all right but i just figured people want
to feel good they want to feel good you
know what i mean oh sure
all right seaman we've prepared for you
a little game okay are you ready for
this
yes
now how are we going to share the album
with him does he have access to it no
but i'll put it on the screen so that's
what he's seeing okay so here's the deal
we've all
prepared feet pictures for you of
ourselves
okay
okay yes we've never done this before
this is our an olive branch to you my
friend an apology for all the uh trauma
we've we've put you through
now the game what i want you to do
they're being they're being sent to you
anonymously
and i want you to rank them for us
before and then at the end we'll reveal
who they are don't worry about hurt
feelings it's okay just be as honest as
you can be honest i'm always the most
honest you're the honest
most honest man alive
all right so let's start from the
beginning
okay
okay
so tell me if you can see it
and we've gone all out we've gone all
out for you on this
okay now just so you know on this the
traditional um
no the traditional um
yeah i see i got i can see it yeah okay
what do you think about that eh what do
you think about the composition
that's pretty it's pretty cool i mean
it's got a little hair in the feet but
that's okay
no hair that's a pretty hairy foot
what i'm seeing no he said there is some
hair on the foot but that's okay
some hair right oh right you like the
hair or you don't like the hair i don't
know i guess i've never had really a
complain about it i just i just when i
see a hot foot i'm just going to go for
it i mean
you don't analyze too much you know what
you like
you know i don't always figure you know
where you like feet like freak too many
people put like limitations that are
like tops more of the balls i mean the
foot's the foot you're really there's
not much you can really make about all
right so so what do you think about this
give us your comments it's not too bad
okay i think it's not too bad i mean
okay
because it's up that way but i'm sure
sideways i could see a lot of it i'm
sure here's another angle
yeah okay toes pretty cool pretty cool
pretty cool
yeah
okay
any comments on the composition at all
no the background's pretty interesting
it's a very reading some kind of a
magical book on a mushroom oh
interesting on a mushroom yeah
okay so that's number one so
how would you so here we got the fairy
foot right here so s tier's the best
it's d is the worst so where would you
put that like
in the this is like the top
in between the second and third i would
say between the second a or b
is now a little bit below before we put
it at c a little bit up a teeny bit up
for the inch upper so yeah that's
probably no that's too much no oh you
went in between right there's no
invitation
yeah yeah you're kind of restricted
too bad that's not too bad so the red is
really good right the reds are really
top one right yes yes
okay so do you want this one b or c
probably between
um between the second to last and like
right in the middle line maybe go down
all right so you you got to pick one
let's just do c
yeah yeah okay good great wow okay this
is actually interesting
not a great not a great rating but we
appreciate the candor
all right moving on
now this one was made with you in mind
my friend
that's pretty good right
i like the difference of backgrounds
like a lot of guys will appreciate that
because you know you see a lot of one
type of thing but the background the
different things like outside that's a
big thing in the foot community
there it is this is an action footage
right and also on a motorcycle footlist
kind of like a vigilante move right
interesting i mean i i don't like
motorcycles like a person but i've seen
some people do that i mean more power to
them i mean that's awesome i mean that'd
be pretty cool it's one year there you
go what do you think about this one
[Music]
a lot of guys want to see souls
what do you think about that eh
nice i would think so yeah pretty nice
yeah
you like the dirt do you like the kind
of nature
well i like the natural i think a lot of
guys do they just you know kind of
afraid to admit it because i think the
natural's just a natural thing plus
we're guys you know we want to have male
strong masculine feet you know rugged
and i think that's how guys want it to
be too so it's good okay sure well this
is exciting
let's go back to the tier list i'm glad
you liked so we got the act the
motorcycle foot what are you thinking
about this one
um a little bit up there like that
that's exactly where it'll be
okay this is exciting i love how like
you know the rating i love it
i didn't see the foot that close up that
i did see from the distance and i like
just it was going to be i guess the
scenery also is a big deal for me too
because you know it's kind of wild and
arrived to have something in city
absolutely
absolutely
all right moving on
we've got a foot in a kind of sea
setting here we're in the ocean
you know uh uh we're we are got a
lighthouse but it's nice it's okay it's
cool you don't like it do you i don't
like it it's pretty nice i think i think
the scenery was probably like the
background the whole thing you like the
ocean and then are you an ocean man
seaman you're a cement
[Laughter]
okay moving on to the second pick here
from the top
um
i think i think we could put that on the
ground
we could do something with that
okay all right
so let's go to the ocean foot um the
mermaid foot if you would just drop that
with no put that next to now let's see
put on see because it's still good
okay
that's terrible yet you can say d be
comfortable
it's got a little something there
yeah
excellent
all right moving on down here
this is a really interesting one so we
only have one photo of this one
but wow what do you think about those
i guess it's okay i mean
they look kind of big don't they
like nail polish i mean some guys you
know but right it's all right so it
looks good the feet look nice i mean
yeah let's see one of that yeah they
look kind of big and veiny and girthy
are you into that
well it's hard to say what kind of foot
i mean i mean i guess like i said like i
said in the first show only you know two
or three feet that really turned me off
like someone was really white and clammy
that like looks like they never got a
sun
we don't like those
i mean you know not that anybody would
but i think you know i think it just
depends on the shape the size the look
the smell the taste i mean you know
smell and taste interesting
yeah i mean there's also other things to
the look because when you get turned on
by a foot you want to see look but i
mean you know i see guys that tell me
well you know it's a certain type of
foot to me i guess it could be some
people like longer bony toes something
like this i really don't have too much
of
a problem with it you know i guess
well i guess we have we have an inherent
issue you can't you can't smell and
taste these foods
which is a big you know criteria
okay so what do we what do we think
about the uh footsies feet where do we
put these ones
um i would say i would say that probably
on that right directly where it is
okay good nice so pretty good huh
all right moving down what do we have
here this is kind of a cupcake theme a
little a bit of a snack if you would
please yes
yeah that's much with food on it but
it's cool and it's kind of fun you know
kind of fun i guess i guess that's all
right i mean i have to see more of the
foot i mean i guess you have another
angle of it or not oh of course i do
yeah
there's here it is stomping on a cake
i'm not really into the whole food
okay
some guys tell me they want to put food
between their toes and it's like i'm not
really into that i know i'm not not into
this
it's okay okay i mean a lot of people
have to
respect him for that i mean we expect
all of our footballers out there because
many guys with switzerland have
different absolutely we respect them all
so so on the
i mean we look at art there's 19
different aspects of art let's be honest
seaman i just want to know if you want a
nut on this foot or not gross
put it there it's perfect okay thank you
let's not consider art all right moving
on oh my goodness this one's in outer
space
holy smokes this is the lunar
landing of feet lots of hair
that's pretty hot
oh
[Music]
here's another angle for you the flag
being planted into the lunar surface
commemorating of course are great
astronauts
1969. who could forget huh
69's a good number too so what the hell
hey come on now who are you kidding huh
69. so what do we think we like this one
yeah that's a bad i would say that's not
to be good all right
outer outer space
going that down the same line there now
the same line was where everything else
is right there yeah see
yeah tough critic man
well we knew we knew yeah we got a
critical eye okay so here this one is is
uh interesting it's kind of a
battlefield
you know um lots of
lots of warfare
uh not too hairy kind of a nice hue if
you would it's a beaut kind of a nice
foot i would say good shape what do you
think
okay
okay another angle here's another angle
for you to judge from you know nice
natural looking foot
it's not too big
yes it's not too bad you don't like it
very much it sounds like i don't like it
i do like it i guess i must put on the
spot for that i didn't think i was doing
this in the show but it's okay it's all
right having fun with it
okay so
then this is the army foot go ahead and
rate the army foot here look at that
same line near you
like you know kind of things i mean i
guess i don't know it's hard to stay i
guess absolutely no don't worry we're
just it's all fun i want you to be
honest
i know it's all fun too yeah yeah and so
this is basically the um the artist foot
if you would interesting
yeah
i like the creativity of trying to
create but let's be honest let's be
honest you you could tell that's is that
a man's foot it's a woman's foot
yeah and you're not you're probably not
even into women
don't think but i mean i still think the
creativity is nice i mean it made it
pretty interesting so i guess you can
give that a little bit of a heads up you
know it's interesting so that's a bit
here's another angle
yeah
it's just the woman's feet you're
probably not into it
no not really but yeah okay it's still
not bad i mean it's still all right so
what do we so the the artist's feet
where do we put this
i'll give a creative put on the same
line then give it that creativity there
it is there it is yeah yep yeah that's
good and finally
hopefully here's one
wow this one is just straight up
nope nope yes
this is the real deal does not you look
like that's pretty hot
i like that i like that yes i like that
here's one more just for
wow mine but that's wait do you like the
you can see you
flip-flop line or no i guess it's okay i
just like barefoot's natural you know
like it's a lot of guys say that too you
know you've seen a lot of stakes that
are warm and guys go barefoot like i
always say to the store i come gasp just
the natural just being out in any way
you do pump gas
somebody go out yes
oh wow that's nice sometimes i see that
a lot before it's normal in like in
florida in warm weather
youtube most people don't care sometimes
you see people getting out and about i
think people just get so weird about
things but you know you want to be
comfortable do you like uh do you like
the um the sh partially shaven or yeah
i mean it's kind of cute the the
flip-flop thing because you could tell
that he wore the flip there at least he
got some color which is he got some
color which we like all right well
finally the flip-flop foot where do we
put this
that would be on the second to no yeah
that line oh
okay well we have a clear winner
well i love each guy i like warm weather
and i like to you know
i can appreciate all right so let's
reveal the the identity of the feat here
uh dan you have the identity you want to
do the honors
uh
sure well um here why don't you put up
the tier list oh you got it yeah i got
it up yes so we have nothing in s rest
in peace nothing in s
uh eight here is actually somebody who's
not here right zach you wanna explain
that is my brother's foot and he has a
size 15 [ __ ]
we figured you'd like that
could smell someone's face in a minute
i guess the california florida
everyone's always tan yeah would you
like him to kind of stomp on your face
with those or what would you like what
would be your fantasy with the size 15
foot i've done a lot so i can't really
say there's so many things i would i
would have to do with that foot you know
oh yes this is driving sometimes drives
to the car cruise control or if you have
one of those old cars at the 90s with
the gear shipped on the steering wheel
you lay down over the hump look at a
guy's feet while he drives pretty wild
you know yeah
that sounds really wild
i actually did that when i visited
california for the first time in 2005 i
was outside san diego and this i met
this person this pickup truck and you
know you had like an old gear shift oh
my god it's cool he's like you want to
get it i'm like okay why not so it was
wild you know so wait he puts his foot
up while he's driving and then you no he
was driving i was over the hump you know
those old cars and 90s with the gear
shift on the steering wheel and you have
the hunt layover so i was laying over
that like flat and just you know going
at the feet that way so you were
you were laying over the stick shift
no there was nothing
with the gear shift on the steering
wheel
they had those ones yeah like the
shifter is like on the side like uh yeah
yeah oh what does that have to do with
the foot well it's just describing the
position it can lay down yeah right lay
down and have room
because it's not in the middle exactly
oh that's good that's good
box
all right so so what who do we have here
on the uh b tier here dan uh click on it
it's actually it's really small on my
screen um oh so that's that that's love
that's our uh that's our swedish uh um
robot over here you ever had a swedish
foot yeah so that's a swedish foot wild
swedish is good that's good that's
lovely we like that
yeah and he he's because he rides a
motorcycle around he figured um you know
this thing isn't necessarily motorcycles
is driving cars i did not know love
drove a motorcycle oh yeah he usually is
a motorcycle he's all about it yeah huh
there's a video to it if you want to
watch it wait hold on let's watch the
video
oh [ __ ] wait hold on uh uh
seaman we made a webs love made a
website bare feet brother drives
drivesmotorcycle.com
and listen before i don't
i'm not trying to steal your thing i'm
making this just just for you oh that's
great no that's wild actually i'm here
it is
at least the guts of dirt
my favorite state pennsylvania
footballers you know foot friend what do
you think about this video
you know that's cool whoa look at that
action shot
whoa
oh
pennsylvania on open road that's cold
you know and we'll do it right that is
super impressive
oh
look at that it's just somebody in
florida like last january when they were
doing that on those mopeds of the time
scooters they were barefoot from the
beach to 7-eleven i was like what
yeah it's pretty cool
all right fantastic yeah that one's love
who's the footsies one
the footsies is a b
okay well congratulations ab
thank you why did you only get one angle
from me what was that oh i'm not sure
it's rigged
well you got the b when sam was asking
what they might want to do i thought it
was just color so i was just like oh
just i don't know from these colors pink
and black but then when she twisted up
the whole themes i was like pretty nice
and then everybody else whose foot you
hated let's be honest
i don't hate them i give them a chance
oh you would know you if you saw this
foot in the club you would never go for
it but just be honest you're being
polite yeah
i mean
i'm not really into that much hair and i
don't think people had hair on their
feet i mean you think hair in a chest
but it's kind of odd how some people
really have lots of hair in their feet
you're the foot expert yeah okay so
who's the mushroom man is cameron right
that's cameron um
that's zach who's the brother of the one
that you really weigh yeah
yeah so it's unfortunate that's your
foot i'm 13. see this is a 13 size foot
you axe there a bit of a change i don't
know the size wasn't bad i mean i guess
that's all right i mean i guess i guess
like i said i'm drawn to like the whole
tan look i mean
i got it it's too pale it's all about
the tail
it's not bad i mean you know
and then this is olivia right yeah so
that's that's actually that's olivia
with the k the lunar landing that one's
ian
damn sorry ian yep i got it too i got
this is me this is mine of course the
foot general right
that was a nice little thing i really
think that was pretty cool i was very
impressed with the eagle's foot i mean i
know it's a woman's foot but i thought
it was looking pretty good
it wasn't too bad i mean i like to see
like i like to create you know why not
so basically um
because normally i don't wait feet
because i'm just kind of like the person
where i just don't let me do that
because even though i'm not perfect and
everyone's when it comes to feet you
just it's not like you know you could
see a person's face over this is great i
mean feet are feet but a lot of ways
it's kind of difficult to describe what
you like about a foot because even if
you've been with someone and like i said
it's really difficult it's a spiritual
thing i think it's more of an inside
thing but i guess it's a numerous things
involved in that i guess the moment
depends on how turned on you are depends
on the moment you're with the person
it's just numerous things when it comes
to that
chemistry yeah all right well semen
it's been a joy to kind of make up you
know make amends figure out what was
going on and to extend this olive branch
to you unfortunately
we weren't able to find an s tier
i was hoping that like his brother with
the 16 feet would be a nest here but
listen
we're going to keep looking okay
that's nice i appreciate that like i
said
there's no hard feelings it's just that
i've actually you know i've got a lot of
great responses positive i had one
negative one but i just mute the person
i got a lot of really good
responsibility
i'm getting people overseas which is
pretty nice to see that they're trying
to upload this overseas argentina
i've got someone from the middle east
he's really cool um i've got two people
from england um someone from bulgaria
which is really nice he's like i've
always had a foot fetish and i want to
be part of this you know those countries
you know they are you know you got to be
as a bit careful on certain things so
it's like pretty nice to have them you
know something right
there you like the dark do you you like
the darker feet colors or do are you
like darker i guess i guess i guess i
could say
especially like in states like the
northeast it's so cold and snowy and
you're in shoes all the time you're all
white and pale and not really healthy
looking i mean it's not right i mean you
can't help but it's freaking 20 feet of
snow outside but you know you kind of
you know you want to miss you wish you
were in arizona or florida or nevada or
california somewhere in great land
um
so you said do you like
okay let's you know what seaman
we appreciate you you take care i know
you're on a uh timeline he's on the time
budget here
which is a little bit which is good but
uh i gotta say i want to do a shout out
to everybody out there it's been great i
love you all um
pennsylvania these men are not going to
be having tanned feet in pennsylvania
i mean i guess i just i guess it's weird
because as a little kid growing up my
family used to go to hershey park every
year like 12 times a year my mother
father just loved princess the weirdest
thing and you know got so tired of it
but i always loved pennsylvania's little
kid seeing harrisburg the amish country
lancaster you ever see an amish foot
i don't know a little bit overly
religious but i don't know i mean
but i've never asked
we can the possibilities are endless
with the smelling and the licking
i like arizona too it's my favorite
steak the one whether it's the kudos to
arizona
people there are a lot of fans in there
you know it's awesome but actually i'm
planning a wrestling shoot in l.a
uh worship wrestling shoot i'm looking
for a ring i'm gonna have a shoot in
miami next month i have six guys going
to wrestle
but keep us posted all right we want to
know everything uh we want to keep
somewhere in hollywood but i found
someone who gave me a connection to a
mansion in palm springs and i've never
been to palm springs i know it's a part
of california most people don't talk
about lots of candies
someone will be kind of
he's going to give alright space into
some foot stuff
all right stephen well you take care
okay
thank you man all right
have a good one all
[Applause]
stopped his right
what
no
it said his full name did they show that
did you see that
okay good
okay good
i was impressed how well the audience
knew whose feet was who's before we were
really well they were pretty accurate
for the most part yeah i felt like we i
guess we should have tried to deceive
him a little more about the women's feet
you know
but uh i think he would have known yeah
don't underestimate this dude
he's a he's foot god yeah he knows his
need
okay
bathroom i find it really interesting
yeah nope nobody can you bring me a 70
and a cheeseburger
i find it interesting though that he did
hone in on your brother's feet which we
knew he would
yeah we said we got to go find a 15 16
foot yeah
so that he goes wild for it i want to
see a picture of his dream foot what's a
s foot for him yeah i need to know
i'm thinking maybe my brother won
because there was no like artistic to it
no i believe what he said
he's very clearly into the tanned look
and your brother's feet they they looked
like he'd been out at the beach
yeah he does walking around the house
taking the dog out that type of [ __ ]
yeah so you know
that sun-baked look that he's into
every other the rest of us spend all of
our time in this studio we don't you
know we got pale ass feet right can you
do
maybe we need to do a setup with my
brother
oh my god
but you know i love that we
hmm tough crowd though like i mean shout
out love he got he got it but we all got
brutalized man he i thought maybe mine
was looking good i thought maybe i had
him but he was like not even interested
a little bit everyone in the chat is
saying that they should do a poll to
pick their favorite foot
oh yeah sure i'm down
i could set that up
um ab you want to tell the story very
clearly
it's just a quick story but zach
insisted that i call his brother on his
birthday to wish him happy birthday i'm
like why are you [ __ ] with me right
now he's like no my brother's a fan he
really would mean a lot to my ass ethan
then you know i don't want you know
whatever ethan's busy let me maybe he's
a fan of you thanks nina maybe he's a
fan of you i'm a fan of you i don't know
why i don't sincerely believe that he
was [ __ ] with me but uh how was the
[ __ ] i just want to get it over with
so i climbed like hey man he goes hey i
go this is a b
zach's co-worker he goes oh what's up
dude i'm like yeah zach just saw me tell
you happy birthday he's like oh thanks
man
i'm like okay i'll see you what's wrong
with this bye it does sound like maybe
he was expecting abe was expecting
something and it maybe abe thought he
was just being [ __ ] with because his
brother was like why are you calling me
no my brother my he my brother likes you
more than me on the show i have a theory
his brother doesn't like me
well no actually the real theory is i
like you zach is i don't know how much
zach is joking but he's made a joke that
uh his brother has the hots for lena uh
or i think selena's hot and so i think
zach was [ __ ] with him and he's like
oh maybe he's pissed he's gonna call you
and punk you out dude why didn't i gotta
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then i called him
and
yeah just because it makes no sense for
me to call him
but that was my story thank you guys
but why i mean but truthfully does he
not want to talk to me because i do feel
like
you know
man would you have called my brother on
his birthday
i would appreciate not being asked right
exactly
yeah
maybe next year i'll shoot you a tax
bill hey it's his birthday
hey it's ethan
you think he would have been more
excited if i called him probably yeah
i mean he's a nice guy but i met him
before should we call out right now
he's actually at work right now oh
wait you're not going to take some a
minute to answer my call we we can you
want to call him
yeah let's talk to him okay bring him up
i got some questions for him let's get
to the bottom of this
do you want him to like zoom in no just
voice is fine
um let's just get to the bottom of this
whole a b conspiracy
okay i'll call him because baby thinks
everyone's scheming all the time
well i'm right and you're you are
usually right
okay i'm gonna call him right now
lena come here is a what's with does amy
have like a what's with his brain he
thinks everyone's scheming
yeah come here
do you think he's always right about
this she said i have a sixth sense
elena's gonna weigh in on this we're
trying to
yeah just that he has a sixth sense
he is good about this what is his sixth
sense what is he good at detecting
schemes
by uh he's good at reading people he was
raised by two lawyers i think that
helped out oh
yeah very interesting right
yeah sometimes the stuff you predict
seems outlandish but he's right like
liam yeah he called liam
on the weirdest [ __ ] okay lina lina sees
it
he didn't answer
oh that's a shame
but his birthday's next year so i know
he'll count on a coffee his birthday's
next year next year next birthday yeah
you're going to call him
well if he calls back let me know
because i i want to probe this a b thing
that's interesting to me what what do
you what do you think i was trying to do
maybe i don't know
i mean i met him already it's not like i
haven't met him like you've talked to my
little brother too my brother likes you
but i've been to your house don't you
think zach would have fessed up to it
now like zach wouldn't lie about it to
this level i don't what does he think i
missed the baby beginning baby thinks
zach asked abe to call his brother yeah
amy thinks he's [ __ ] with him
what what like i don't understand why
did you call or not yet no i did and it
was so awkward it was like 30 seconds
like hey zach told me to call your
birthday happy birthday he's like oh
thanks man well then and it seemed like
it seemed like he didn't care he didn't
care exactly maybe he was just nervous
though he likes trying to try and i mean
he's a really nice guy i don't know
i i just don't see the problem with the
[ __ ] birthday call why does it gotta
be something
why is there gonna be something more to
it
i guess i just underestimate my club i
don't know
all right
actually speaking of overestimating your
clout
a b is going to be boxing oh we're doing
the big reveal oh we're not supposed to
talk i mean probably not uh whatever he
didn't tell me anything i don't owe
anyone anything i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't know anything about nothing
ian's putting together this boxing match
idubbbz you guys saw in the um
absence of rice gum
and then [ __ ] apparently there's
gonna be like 10 fights
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i just peeked over
he was [ __ ] got dude i swear to god
your feet looked hella good
a lot of money selling feed pics you
know that was like a big thing for me to
share that i i'm always so insecure
about my feet dude yours were looking
like good i'm not a feet person so i
don't like will you stomp on my face
tonight no i want to smell those bad
boys
oh [ __ ] i left out cam of the pool oh my
bad
sorry can you smell him
uh no
do people really think that mine was
better than zach's
brother are they just voting for me
i love it's ranking very high i've been
olivia uh and elo those three seem to be
running away with it how does that feel
love they love uh loves video yeah
i mean he put in that work man he
deserves it yeah i spent like two hours
on that [ __ ] today
did you feel unsafe driving your
motorcycle with with those shoes that
seems kind of sketch yeah of course yeah
i drive a lot of motorcycles and then i
mean the first rule is to have gear
have the right gear right now that goes
against all the
all the rooms i didn't realize you're
such a badass bro
how long have you been riding motorcycle
uh
since a kid
really since i was 16.
is that something your family's into or
just like your own interest
uh my dad
rides a little bit
[Music]
i don't know just something i picked up
i guess
love were you worried burning your feet
on the motorcycle because i've run
through i do i
because i've run through all my shoes
when i used to have a bike
yeah
that's scary yeah it's pretty sexy uh
that's some sex appeal there love i
gotta say
yeah he earned a lot of uh
yeah i think he just learns a few simps
in the chat definitely with some feet
some motorcycling kind of cool kind of
badass no shoes on the bike
yeah i mean
hello
anyway um what were we talking about
oh yeah aby's gonna fight someone in
this [ __ ] [ __ ] show of a fight which
is gonna be awesome for the show
ian was like we need another fighter
is anyone on your crew want to do it
at first he asked if zack wanted to do
it because the opponent was like six too
freaking like this monk he's kind of
like monsters though like jack the gym
rat
and zack's like [ __ ] no basically right
zach
yeah which is fair enough i'm gonna said
i'm gonna be uh abs mick though i'm
gonna train him like rocky
if i die in the ring dancing he's gonna
avenge me like rocky he's gonna go train
in russia and then benjamin you gonna
are you going to train yeah so i've been
talking with idubbbz um he found a place
near me and i'm going to meet with them
soon so oh my goodness definitely
it's a bit it's a charity event so i
don't even know if baby's going to get
paid but they're going to pay for his
training
and they're going to fly him out to
florida for the event which is going to
be great like i said great for the show
bad for me not playing i think it'll be
good for you why not i was very excited
to do it are you excited to get jacked
are you excited just to kind of get in
the ring you like the clout you're
trying to get your cloud out i'm excited
to get in shape definitely
are you scared
slightly it hasn't really hit me yet the
guy is a lot bigger than me but
he's the same sighting okay but he's way
heavier he's like a gym rat jacked
muscular he's a little taller than me
but yeah i i'm my money's on no i think
he's gonna whip his ass is he also an
influencer kind of thing or what's the
yeah dude i don't i don't know i guess
he's part of some other like group
collective so i guess it's fitting in
that regard mm-hmm
you guys gonna be like the undercard
undercard undercard fight would be in
the parking lot
no i don't know anything about him i'm
not saying anything about him but not
anything about him but i saw a picture i
was like i haven't [ __ ] fight that
guy
so brave
kind of exciting for the show
it's going to be cool
definitely memes coming up for that dude
do they know when it's happening or not
yet it's in like
early next year spring
yeah i believe they said i don't think
the date's completely pretty good
yeah pretty exciting pretty good meme
right there yeah
it's exciting
and um
what if he [ __ ] what if he like [ __ ]
you up though like you got this
beautiful face that everyone loves
i'm okay if i just don't embarrass
myself too much i'll be happy
you you ever fight you fight oh yeah
when i was younger but
that's what i'm saying i'm not afraid to
get hit so i think that's a
big advantage you think you've got a
strong jaw
yeah really i'm more confident in
getting hit and thrown hits so is there
like the one with the gloves yeah it's
it's like it's not they probably have
probably 20 inch gloves and probably
helmeted almost certainly oh
i mean
impossible but i don't but yeah it's not
as intense it's not as intense as a as a
real boxing man ethan's gonna be my
manager i'll have him negotiate
my nose
well i was like okay i was like okay ian
how much how much we talk in here
he's like it's a charity event i said
cut the crap
[ __ ] the chair how much my boy getting
i get five percent
we'll see if we get you a little
something
you know we're gonna need more than five
percent anymore
with peace and love get love a new
monitor
dude this is not just a monitor this is
a four thousand dollar robot it's not
that easy you guys that said without
we don't want to give away too much but
they're
they're there's a there's a love bot
revision in the works let's just say
that and it's we're very excited about
it um oh yeah thank you so the same
person said that they would love to see
a day in love's life
segment
a dane loves life that sounds like a
good a good idea
sure sure
what's your day like what's a day of
love's life like i mean that
would probably not be that fun i don't
do a lot tell me about it
i work i play some video games
i drive some motorcycle
i drop some cars
that's pretty much eat some pizza i eat
some kebab pizza okay i actually have
some pizza right here oh let me see that
i want to hold on what is that you got
fries on it wait how do you see it
i can't do it
[Music]
yeah that's literally just ranch
dressing i'm sorry bro no trust me i
i've had rash dressing this is not
russia i've had so many dms talking
about it
it's for for a fact not
what is that thing's huge oh yeah bro
what is it called
it's kebab sauce oh we you missed our
conversation
apparently this thing kebab sauce unique
to his city that everybody losing their
[ __ ] mind over really and it's like a
secret
recipe that nobody can duplicate
and it's pizza with french fries on it
and kebab
yeah i mean usually the normal one is
without fries but you know it's just
kind of like an extra treat
and i'm yo i'm gonna shout out the
pizzeria i go to
tol vance pizzeria the 12. shout out 12
months
oh yeah i'll see you there at five love
all right dude
i'll buy you some pizza can we get some
it's my cheat day today
oh it is i've been good all week i've
been having like a good week okay and i
didn't eat anything today
so what i'm thinking is pizza with
french fries topped with ranch
and also if you could stomp your foot on
it i'll push up your foot
all right let's move on we got so much
to get to guys
um
by the way did you see nick acado call
me ugly
he didn't say you're ugly did he i heard
what he said
here it is
by the way wouldn't it be an interesting
interview like i
i kind of want to because i don't know
anything about him i mean the guy's
story and everything is
what is the story he started as this
vegan
yeah
super skinny him and his husband or
boyfriend i don't know if they're
married
and then
over time they started doing these mook
bangs and i guess apparently it took off
for him
and now they're like both massive
they eat like crazy
and also he does like
really hardcore
gay porn oh really on only fans right
like gnarly [ __ ] i've heard i haven't
seen it but like like gaping [ __ ] dude
okay
i'm back checking that yeah yeah i i i i
don't want to put out the wrong like um
chad would like an interview but i
thought actually i just find him
actually funny and interesting also he
had a crazy spout with trisha
oh which is like yeah of course
everything goes back to tristan he was
like a super fan of hers and then he
went to meet her in la and she like
flaked on him
and they turn into this huge beef right
is that what happened
uh i'm sorry i was looking at some oh
did you see something i saw some stuff
here what did you see
was that right
uh yeah yep yep
but that's so interesting that he also
does like more like who would have
thought who would have
expected all that
is it is it like gaping
i it's enough to leave an impression
after a split second keeping somebody
said he's a troll don't fit into it
unless he takes a serious interview as
himself yeah i wouldn't take a i would
obviously just want a serious interview
as himself
can you send what you saw like i just
want to look at it okay so if you want
to divorce
wait they still make videos together
troll a lot so i don't know this is him
this is him when he started youtube oh
crazy i
watched him from them from when he was a
vegan wow so i was saying i think he'd
be an interesting person to interview i
love
okay oh yeah so i think i should do that
because i'm looking for people i'm
really interested in that i think would
be yeah obviously i would just do it as
him as himself you know
can you send me the uh i i want to make
sure i facilitate this correctly since
we're live
yeah put it on the i'm going to send in
discord and don't show yeah obviously
ela i want to show you
what i'm talking about in terms of the
i haven't seen it either so
send it here did you drop it
wait so i have to click it okay so be
really careful yeah
don't show anything
because it's going to open it oh my god
dude why did you send it like a link i
wanted you to drop a oh there's some
variety in there holy okay
look at this i don't i don't need to see
it
holy [ __ ] bro that is vile oh my god
i've never seen this
yeah yeah
it's like super gnarly men are doing
impossible things
men are doing impossible things yeah
nicotine he eats the food in his [ __ ]
capes
he's getting it he's getting railed by
impossible pieces
by orlan
orland's his husband
oh okay well anyway i think he's
interesting
that was beyond vile
toxic masculinity dan came back from the
bathroom without any contact
i walked by and it was on his screen i
was just like whoa
and i got nervous and i took it off real
quick the point is obviously i think he
knows it's vile like that's kind of like
the whole like
character yeah yeah
the point is is that he does like the
most hardcore
imaginable
in the top and on the bottom all holes
stuffed
and emptied
and everything in between
anyway here he is the reason we're
talking about him
is because he called me ugly you believe
this guy what do you think although
there does seem to be a good amount of
people who don't want to see it really i
don't know i don't know why people
dislike him like i get he's it's hard to
gauge like how many
how
like when
especially towards the beginning when he
was finding his character he and orlan
would there there was like some
narratives that were verging on abusive
oh
because i stuff i always saw was just
like
it wasn't like harmful trolling like
stuff trisha does it was like just goofy
as if like but i'm not super familiar
yeah i think as of recently he's been
more goofy goofy like people are memeing
on him can we do a poll
you guys want to see this or no
not that i shouldn't even leave it up to
you guys i should say
you're saying see the interview yeah
okay yeah i mean i don't want people if
they think he's like uh a problem
but anyway here's the clip while you
guys you wanna set that up dan the poll
what should we interview him yeah is the
question yeah should ethan klein do you
think he's attractive why you asked that
h3h3
oh him yeah
do i think he's attractive
if i have to think about this
not my type okay although he probably
has a nice belly i do like bellies on
guys
that's a that's a thing for me
um also depends what you know it looks
like you know down there did take a
photo one time posting like kim
kardashian turned around
it was like a selfie and it was just
like crinkly but then they like put in
an ice cream cone his butt looks like
mine crankly and smashed
yeah i mean he said he you like your
belly
so i don't know i don't think i'm just
so he didn't call me ugly she forced him
to answer him well that's the answer i
expect anyone to honestly give if they
ask if they're attracted to me and
sometimes
oh yeah do i think he's attractive if i
have to think about this no okay okay
not my type okay
don't worry you're not my type either
feelings mutual
people are saying yes
the yeses uh seem to have guesses or
went out i'm telling you guys it would
be an interesting interview a real one a
personal one
even the nays would be captivated okay
let's go
we're gonna make that happen guys
what was his drama with trisha i'm just
i remember there was like a huge thing
was all over that what was it so the way
that their connection started was he was
like a huge fan of her and he released a
video of him because he's a trained
violinist
so her violist whatever it is he
i don't know he played one of her songs
and then she commented on the video i'm
pretty sure and then they struck up like
a friendly online thing and
orlan
lives in columbia and for something for
nick to get his visa he had to come to
la for a few days and so he dm trisha
asking to film and hang out and she said
yes and then when he got here she didn't
answer his text messages
so she she bailed she goes right and
then um people
got very upset when he posted the
exposed video and then they filmed
together and then a girl named stephanie
sue posted kind of an exposed video on
nick and then
trisha essentially was like why didn't
people listen to me when i said wait
people turned on nick they did for
because it was like bizarre i wasn't
necessarily able to follow it it was
like he was taking pictures inside of
her house but he was saying is because
he wanted better security
and i'm not super up to date on
i mean he's very interesting that's why
i watched based on my experience so far
i'm just going to go ahead and side with
him
he was
okay all right well anyway moving on
come on
come on zach
on fridays we banned those summers okay
yeah so
ela i don't know if you saw
we took a vote on the favorite toilet
okay did you did you get a chance to
watch that's something i did not watch
yet so this was um cameron cameron
created basically he's he inadvertently
recreated
donald trump's bathroom
he would take issue with your
characterization sorry but that's what i
see this is
not going to job i think it's a star
camp says he doesn't endorse that one
it is what it is
it's supposed to be a uh he's very nice
supposed to be a replication of the
aesthetic from the 1990s sitcom frasier
it's supposed to be sort of like a
classy upscale uh
downtown uh seattle apartment
right and then this was ian's i believe
no no that's mine oh that's dan's the
kind of like uh
this i would call this the um
splash mountain aesthetic
yeah okay that's a fair characterization
yeah it's supposed to be you know uh uh
oneness with nature sort of zen garden
environment
yeah you do a zen garden while you [ __ ]
and then there's a koi in the
tank obviously that's stressful that is
stressful isn't it and then oh this was
a nice touch there's a cherry blossom
tree with a projector with a live cherry
blossoms making the petals kind of like
fall on all the walls around you the
whole time so you're kind of in a
mystical forest this was abs oh my god
we don't know it's just a generic
looking guy how did you guys create
these
um the geniuses here at the h3 podcast
cameron and ian right
that's what we want and then they uh
and then they actually built all of them
to scale
so that we could take these photographs
and then we tore them all down which we
realized after the fact was probably we
shouldn't have torn them down because we
could have just used them for the
bathrooms right well on a serious note
we've pledged to try to create the
winner's bathroom seriousness
you know within reason
so this is um abs which i really like
this one i was like damn why didn't
think of that so he's sitting and
staring at himself so yeah you
this fictional i don't know about the
mere one
i need to see it happen this fictional
character that i made up in my mind
whenever you [ __ ] in his mouth you you
look in the mirror and you take pride in
it
any likeness to
real
people is pure coincidence yeah i just
close my eyes and imagine this person
gotcha
also love the angle so the audience
knows i am spamming the um
excuse me the poll in the chat right now
this is another this is your last chance
to get your votes in just because this
pers this imaginary person can't hide
their baldness with the smaller hat good
yeah
coming down this is mine
needs a little explanation but
it's a lazy boy that you sh that you sit
on and there's a tube for putting your
dick in and peeing in also there's an
attachment for the women you're going to
figure that out you know
you need some kind of attachment but
you're just in his face so when you
there's a sensor in the toilet when you
start pooping you enter warp speed
every wall is a
is a television full immersion
as you wipe
you entered an asteroid field
you can actually navigate it with the
direction you want
and then as you finish
you land to
10 000 cheering bookies
mission accomplished
a little bit expensive probably hard to
difficult one
this was ian's i believe 20 000 leagues
under the sea
yep
beautiful you actually and a little bit
of a hentai touch with the tentacle
which cleans your ass at the end
that's right so did we conclude is that
is that a prostate massager too yeah it
can double as that yeah okay i think we
yeah that
okay somebody in the comments pointed
out that it's sort of the aesthetic of
those 90s point-and-click adventure
games if you remember at all
kings quest it it restored a memory in
my brain of uh freddy the fish
and oh i love this game sure enough it's
uh it's very much ian's aesthetic here
fascinating you so you did play freddie
the fish ian i did
mentally loosely inspired by yeah yeah
good vibes for sure
so here and then this is ian's he had
the sculpture of himself as poseidon i i
didn't
it's not it's not
exactly
now this would be loves
oh
is uh a swedish shrine to the king
a flag of ikea and shawarma so
this was olivia's it's a disco party
the party pooper
and zach's of course which is basically
i i was trying to think about this like
yeah it's basically like what a 10 year
old thinks an adult's bathroom looks
like
[Laughter]
this is that
better figure it out
using our lauren savior
it has a meat bar
looking
i spent a lot of time in the bathroom so
i figured you got a kitchen right there
saves time
and you know that meat is going to give
you diarrhea anyways so yeah it's just a
cycle you just stay there all day yeah
you got you gotta you know dan even was
a proponent of this like you know it'd
be pretty sick to have a stack of
marshalls in a bathroom
uh it was more so that i just liked that
you were baiting ethan into buying us a
bunch of marshall stuff
i thought that was very clever what did
i buy marshall
those amplifiers
oh i see you just want me to buy
marshall's stuff
well that was kind of my thought was
like this
his whole bathroom design was really
just a backdoor way of getting him just
trying to buy a bunch of hams off me
yeah exactly so anyway here's all the
choices you guys uh the votes are in
yeah the poll is still pinned uh we're
gonna reveal the results in just a
second here this is your last chance all
right plenty of time let's pull it up
all right so stand by i'm going to it's
been up since yesterday
this thing has got ample opportunity to
get the votes
so all right it is loading the responses
right now i'm actually in real time
seeing the number tick up can you put it
on the screen i don't have access to it
i got you all right here it is
with 20 000 responses the winner is
abs bathroom
[Applause]
with about 25 of the vote uh a close
runner-up is olivia with a silent disco
experience interesting
[Music]
almost 22 of the vote uh third place is
actually mine with almost twenty percent
this is the whole zenforest experience
that's right uh
in fourth it looks like we have ian's
the ian submarine under the sea
experience
uh followed by love's uh rustic swedish
cabin experience and then uh let's see
it doesn't show the percentage i got
absolutely took a massive l on this one
yeah ethan with four percent looks like
he's like that last me or zach uh it
looks like cam and zach's are pretty
much tied love you cam nobody i'm sorry
cam nobody wants to [ __ ] and pressure
yeah technically cam's last but only by
just a handful of votes there by about
10 votes
they're a little acquired taste but
that's okay so yeah zach and cam are
pretty much tied in the last place
position there
yeah that i mean
those are those ones were very
personalized i think that was the
problem like so personalized that nobody
would ever want to use those bathrooms
about you guys
before yourself dude
i don't i speak for everybody that voted
bro i i would be happy with cams like
it's it's not olivia's bathroom
yeah i like olivia's a lot too and i
mean so did the audience evidently you
know i'm hearing a lot of commentary
from a bunch of losers uh
it's nice to win guys thank you so much
appreciate you
i never what are you saying are you
gonna carve that toilet i'm
oh you're you're gloating well i was
oh
kidding
just about to turn the focus on abe the
winner
this is actually like a very doable
maybe the most doable of all of them i
mean
yeah i had that in mind i had that in
mind how do you get the toilet to look
like well you have to customize it
well i've actually had okay so yeah
already who do this kind of thing on
twitter okay so let me let me just be
totally serious here for a minute
is making that toilet too far that's
what i want there like like too far
morely
get banned
i feel like it's beyond the channel like
real life
morals
it's like he's not that important to me
this fictional character
i think we should take a pull on this
one because maybe i appreciate the
it's funny the concept is funny yeah
we know what the polls gonna say
you think they're gonna say it's too far
no they're gonna say it's not too far i
think they're gonna say it's too far
really because it's kind of psychotic
let's be honest yeah a little bit it's a
little psychotic
to actually make it as as willing as i
am to waste money on dumb things for the
show
i don't want to come off as a absolutely
unhinged psychopath well let's find out
is it too far so that's the audience
yeah
here we go i think it's gonna be
well
i think it's gonna be a vast okay well
it's closer than i thought it's close
but
you guys know that's insane like like
people if we actually did that people
would say look how psychotic this guy is
and you could be laughing at
those people while you're [ __ ]
and reading those responses like a king
looking at yourself
yeah it's 54 to a percent yes it's too
far
um i thought it would be more you guys
are a little crazy
that'd be like overwhelming
you know i don't think i should build
that toilet with peace and love
we could put it in your apartment we can
build it and put it in your apartment
no it's all good
thank you
so does this mean it goes to the number
two spot no hmm
oh no
oh so just nothing happens nothing
happened wait why not well what was the
number two one it was olivia
okay guys that one's achievable yeah you
think so yeah oh yeah totally pretty
good yeah
i mean not the dj there 24 7 living on
the roof of the bathroom yeah actually
let's skip that part
but yeah we could deck it out it's like
yeah
here let's pull the picture back up yeah
that one we could put a mirror in it for
a b
to go
abe
loves himself so much he wants to watch
him stop [ __ ] like that
bro
there's plenty of time in the day to
look in the mirror you don't have to
watch yourself yeah there's never been a
mirror where i could watch myself doing
that we could make a garbage can in the
shape of
this whole thing was rigged from the
get-go you won
you didn't what did i win
you want to ruin my life
like i will you'll ruin my life if i
make this i can't do this okay i want
you know like part of me wants to
but
it's kind of embarrassing it's crazy to
actually makes you actually right yeah
imagine imagine having guests yeah
exactly and they're like can i use the
restroom and they go in there and they
see that they're gonna tell everyone and
it'll be legendary oh this is the
legendary toilet
let me go do you think
i'm so [ __ ] in the head
better be like the photo spot
i don't know bro it's just weird i'll
get i'll regret it but the party pooper
no don't get me wrong i love the idea
it's funny
considering that no conceptually yeah
i'm kidding i'm not i'm not part about
it like i said almost everybody in your
apartment
yeah we could totally do this that's
completely achievable i've been
listening to olivia the entire time i
mean it's so foreboding we can maybe get
some mannequins up there to make it look
like there's oh like simulate it yeah oh
that's interesting you know yeah
i like that okay let's look into this
this is good so it's a silent
poop scout right olivia
yeah silent disco party so there are
headphones um
you'll figure
well i guess the communal [ __ ]
headphones is not is gross
yeah stan
yeah
that is true actually
i'm just putting like a crazy subwoofers
and [ __ ] shake the poop out of you
when that bass drops your poop also
drops
thank you
all right i gotta go pee but up next
there's something everyone was been
waiting for we found out that one of our
favorite topics on the show wendy
williams yeah had a mega beef
with someone else we recently talked
about judge mathis right
die
we looked into it and it's really
interesting okay so i'm this is going to
be fun
um i'm going to come back i'm going to
be right back ela
all right it's all on you now
you enjoy that basic toilet
um let's see
kem's idea should have won
well there's about 2.3 of the audience
that agrees with you
correct
peace and love what's going on with abs
so nervous lately are you okay bro
now i am not explaining i don't know i
don't know like i feel like so my body
movements don't match how i feel inside
i just i just tremor i don't know i have
a tremor
sometimes my voice cracks it happens
he's always like i'm so shaky i'm so
shaky that i'm like no you're not like
like you're gonna calm down like
oh yeah i just need to tell my hands hey
listen i know you've been doing this
[ __ ] for 30 years just [ __ ] well it's
not like you have a full body shape you
have anxiety stop it just stop it yeah
you know what we'll fix that
just two three sips of beer oh yeah
that's true you need to do that's the
keemstar advice you need to take deeper
breaths what about trying to say
ian's shaky too what about him have you
ever tried just nothing
he was more shaky when he started
working here right yeah
yeah i stopped i just chose not to do it
[Laughter]
i was over it the gag was boring yeah
well once a b came in and kind of stole
your bit it's like all right i guess
i'll stop
sorry dude yeah i was
there is an important question here do
you guys tell each other when you go to
poop
when we go
i'm very [ __ ] shy
oh yeah ab hides i used to go upstairs
but now there's people upstairs so yeah
i just hold it in and suffer no
maybe that's why i've been shaking more
lately those were not good
yeah it means we had dibs on
the left and the right one those were
sanctuary no one else gave a [ __ ] to
like walk all the way upstairs so
whenever i gotta go the bathroom i have
to like i feel so bad because dan has to
get out of this like big rig to come
over because he has to switch so
it's a lot i know i've tried to figure
out a way that i can like remote control
and switch the shoes should we show the
side views yeah i was about to say can i
cut do you have anything on your screen
uh
yeah it's okay
oh finally yeah
look at this
you got it but they shot it you have to
yeah because like you don't appreciate
that's the real the chair from just a
straight shot
i wasted five thousand dollars on this
thing
better damn well see it
so ian i'm requesting now you need to
just randomly cut to that shot when
dan's talking well also i i don't know
what is what's on his screen yeah
well as long as it's not nicodo's gaping
[ __ ] we're fine
you know what you need like the bankers
they have this like
screen that you don't see anything from
the side
is it just like a sticker on the screen
it's just a little like sheet of plastic
interesting yeah yeah
i hate that thing by the way
when you sit with a banker it's like
horrible it's like
you just feel but it's great for them
yeah it's great it's actually it's like
it's great for everybody it's just
annoying to not be able to see what
they're looking at there's something
that teachers would do especially when i
was in high school that if you would try
to take a picture of the board like the
smart board for your homework
yeah like i've never heard an old
goddamn smart board i'm serious
it's like a
like a projector type thing that you can
draw on
this is the fan the school has changed a
lot yeah schools
yeah
you've never heard of a smart no i've
heard of it but it's definitely after
ethan and i's time
i remember chalk yeah
we have [ __ ] chalkboards my high
school mainly had um white boards or
that's what they would use but
whiteboard what's a whiteboard
okay no we have white
but there was there was something that
they could put on like a feature they
could put on their smart board where if
you tried to take a photo of it so if
you try to put a camera up to any of it
it blocked it out with like rainbow
lines why would they not want you to
take a photo because they want you to
use your hand to write i guess
i want you to just snap
snap the notes they want you to like
actually take notes yeah what's wrong
how do why do they care i think
theoretically
because i think you know theoretically
take writing it down makes you remember
it more easily okay well maybe you learn
different ways [ __ ] do that true
i mean you're in class like why do you
need to control how they you know what
i'm saying
i mean i hated it i was just trying to
take a picture of my homework it's like
not that serious that they need to be
like nobody did you ever did they ever
have a the overhead projectors or is
that was that totally gone that was part
of the smartboard they also had the
the projectors where
they could put paper on it and right
right experience that's actually what it
meant like transparencies yeah we did
that remember that what other crazy
technology do you do do you guys use in
hi in school i don't know because i
didn't think a smart board was crazy
are there so so do you guys what kind of
things smart boards have been around
forever no they haven't since i was in i
think i'm telling you not when i was in
forever is in like ten years that's not
foreign
we got our i saw my first smart board
yeah okay hold on guys this is gonna
shock some of you but i graduated from
high school in like 2004 yeah 2005 for
me so yeah we did not have smart boards
there ain't no goddamn and also and even
if they were invented they
my
high school did not have them so okay
everything was dumb i actually feel like
a boomer for the first time in my life
genuinely there was no smart product
period boomer
i've never felt like such a boomer so
wait did you guys how often are you
using computers in your school
i mean in college every single class
yeah yeah yeah but like in high school
in high school um
they wouldn't let us use computers in
class yeah
okay i think that well we had like
chrome books that the school owned that
they would like wheel into the classroom
if we needed to use so like we i don't
think we used our laptops
when i was in elementary school my first
elementary school the screens were black
and green only
they were that [ __ ] old oh yeah same
yeah that was the first computer
oregon trail it was just dos
yeah i remember them teaching us basic
and [ __ ] like the programming language
dude dogs was the [ __ ] i'm not even
gonna lie like those were kind of the
best days of gaming in my in my opinion
i don't know if you remember trying to
like clear uh memory from dos hard drive
space oh yes yeah you had to actually
know the commands and everything you had
to like know the file directory and type
it exactly
[Music]
good times
it was good we're all little hackers
all right well um
[ __ ] hackers all right you guys want
to do this uh wendy owens first judge
mathis
healy you want to update us you're
looking at your baby chart i checked uh
because i saw someone ask what size is
it now so it's the size of a head of a
cauliflower
head of a cauliflower
that's right that's pretty big
i mean i've seen that i see the heads of
cauliflowers very wildly in size
they change a lot in size oh yes
right so it's not a good i don't think
it's a good
but i was just at the doctor and you
that's that's that like that could be
huge i think that's probably what
they're talking about because the last
one was a eggplant i think they said
that he weighs like 2.9 pounds now so
whoa that's almost like
i mean at five pounds that's like in the
range of normal small normal
holy [ __ ] this one look at this eggplant
that's the best all right this
cauliflower look how proud and they look
like they're proud of their baby there
too
mommy do you like it do you like
cauliflower mommy i actually ate
cauliflower
oh copper is good
yeah why do you hate it
it's just it's just the flavor the
texture everything
and alfredo wants to say hi to
cauliflower
oh
cauliflower
cauliflower
wait wait wait wait
keep holding it yeah hold on very still
please you better get the shredder too
mom i don't want to ignore you and get
ready on the crossfit
[Laughter]
[Music]
should i breastfeed him yeah
[Music]
are you crossfading because i just yeah
yeah i i have to put it on the screen to
do it but yes
we're seeing uh an overlay here shredder
mom what is in his bed oh he is i
thought he was yeah
he's afraid
[Music]
you deserve everything
[Music]
you should recreate this picture and
post it on twitter
[Music]
by the way um we're starting to get
nervous it's like it's gonna happen
before we know it at this rate the baby
uh end of january right yeah roughly
that's not too far from now
i gotta put you down you wanna say hi
mom
hi
go to mama
shredder you wanna come say hi
come here shreddy
[Music]
all right let's do this wendy williams
judge mathis
do you guys want to order food by the
way is that a thing i think lina is
getting us food that's okay but hold on
lena don't go too healthy on me now it's
friday
what are you ordering lena
you know i don't know if she's here
mommy's always on the move
don't go
and you said don't listen to me right so
now it's a real test for her
don't go too healthy
don't go too healthy on me now
oh
me now
it's friday it's my cheat day
cheat day
alina told me to order a salad for you
[ __ ]
what did you get sam
huh
oh you don't like that
you're not good
not good
i mean a meatball just a meatball i mean
what am i gonna do with that
it
you can also do my sandwich if you want
you come to me on a friday
it's a cheat day
with a salad why is friday today
shouldn't it be the weekend
you're going to do the whole weekend at
your weekend i'm there
you come to me at this disrespect
a whole week of eating good 1500
calories a day
the whole weekend's a cheap meal no
respect
and now on this beautiful friday
i haven't eaten all day a salad
[ __ ] bull again
[Laughter]
a meatball
absolute
where would we be without men making
meatballs
on a friday
ethan's done impossible things this week
he's done four podcasts he's taking care
of his son his dogs his pregnant wife
and what does he get for this a salad on
a friday
it's toxic
it's unthinkable
and sex with men
men don't get the respect where would we
be without men the man deserves a pizza
at least or a hamburger with french
fries
they work themselves to death women
don't women don't work like men
he did four podcasts
what did you get to eat dan
dan
what did you get to eat
oh i nobody asked me
um
about food oh you did i i didn't get
anything
it's mine [ __ ] you
what'd you get sam what was the extra
thing
eggplant parm sandwich let's go you're
not getting any of that no no
i got a spicy chicken sandwich if you
want oh what did you get for me
now we're all talking about food
oh you are here oh let's go
it's just for these women get eggplant
sandwiches and men who are doing
impossible things get salads
it's unfair
it's unbelievable i don't see tears
[Music]
just you're [ __ ] yeah
i cannot believe i have to eat a salad
i'm gonna call your therapist right now
sounds good i mean dude
that's he he messaged lina
it's not her fault to get him healthy
food and to not listen
not her fault
oh [ __ ] even what's going on
because you say what you want say what
you want i feel like i need to clear my
name because ethan you asked me to take
on this position of um guarding you know
what you do or don't eat so
i'm just trying to help first of all
thank you you're welcome
yes i know you you're fulfilling your
duties admirably like nobody it takes a
lot of courage and strength to protect
me from myself
uh you're only doing what it was
instructed so i by no means i'm trying
to uh
attack your character in fact i am
complimenting your character thank you
very much with that being said um i'm
gonna need you to step then
okay just because it's friday do you
want something something good on the
side
apparently i got a meatball
do you like meatballs do you like meat
though
[Laughter]
the bread is gratuitous know your way
around some meat
it's damn a little inappropriate
disgusting
all right well i'm gonna probably dan
sounds like he didn't want his permanent
family
all right thank you lina you're doing a
great job we love you
uh
yes
you know okay how about we get something
fun for dinner okay now we're talking
for dinner you want to talk to me about
you
i don't care about what they eat
what do you want to eat for dinner how
is this done it's not going to be clear
this conversation doesn't involve you
we're going to eat at like 4 30 5
o'clock i mean that's that's support
time dan what
did anybody ask you anything are you
eating are you telling me you don't eat
it again today well i might but i'm
would you call it lunch eating a meal
like 4 30
oh we are clearly i mean the sun is
going to be down it's like it's not
lunch of the sunset i'm sorry you have
to be 60 and up to call this dinner what
the [ __ ] you'll be going for the earth
it's closer to it's closer to dinner
than it is it's lunch it's a dungeon
[Music]
yeah lunch is noon it's dungeons
noon is closer to breakfast you want you
exactly thank you either okay just
because you guys are who eats lunch at
noon
12 year olds and 80 year olds
[Laughter]
what time is lunch to you what time is
launch two now three two three yeah
that's too late i'd agree that's the
little dude that's late lunch yeah i
like a one or a two
so i can deal with it in an ideal world
yes one but sometimes it doesn't happen
sure it's so true
it's three it's three o'clock we're
having let's be generous and say it's
two o'clock two o'clock lunch right
that's lunch and so when's dinner
uh it's like seven
nine nine
nine o'clock is dinner too
that's what they do there
when in paris baby when in rome when in
rome where they're exotic or israeli
we mix it up
ordinary
[Laughter]
well the thing for us is that like
i i did find it funny when i first moved
here
um
i feel like you we were a lot with your
parents and they would be like all right
we're going for dinner and it's like
four yeah and i was like that for sure
is an awesome thing to have like the
super early
dinner
but because my parents just wake up for
like five for no reason by default you
know
still they somehow can't get to our
house till 11. someone explained that to
me
wake up at five
we say be here by 10.
they got they get their 12.
explain that to me they wake up
maybe it's genetic
releasing the
butterflies some theory some plausible
theory there damn
all right so we got food i'm going to
eat a salad and [ __ ] i don't really
want to pull about this oh one well well
how do you even how do you even phrase
the point here's what you could do
optimal lunchtime is you could do like
11 a.m 12 1 i mean anybody says 11 is a
psychopath like that okay so that's two
so let's start at 12 okay just because i
didn't because you said 12 and i don't
want that to be the first option
i think you've got to do 11. optimal
lunch some people lead at 11.
11 12
1
2 1 clock line 3 go up to even 4. the
youtube polls only give you four options
okay so
that's fine
optimal lunch time 11 12 1 2. this is
actually gonna this is a poll i'm
interested in here all right let's see
what the community says i'm gonna vote
on this one myself
because i feel passionate about it i
usually abstain lunch time as the show's
host
but this time
i'm going to our youtube channel
looks like one has the early lead but 12
is second place
wow okay i'm voting
i mean one yeah one's fine i like one
you know i like one 12 is
i don't know yeah but so so i'm okay
with one being there you know
12 is like you're starting to get hungry
in my head why can't i vote it doesn't
even let me vote oh because you you're
probably on the account that created the
poll oh i'm logged in
yeah what's breakfast for you guys
breakfast isn't much i mean i don't [ __ ]
with breakfast but on the weekend if we
get breakfast it's probably at like 12.
see
i'm not going to criticize you guys but
you can't like act like it's crazy
when you you guys clearly have like a
out of the ordinary eating schedule you
don't eat breakfast you eat lunch in the
late afternoon breakfast now that i'm
pregnant i accept that you know what i
mean i ate it now everybody holds these
standards around 10.
breakfast
nine okay that's fine can i be honest i
think breakfast
this whole thing about breakfast being
the most important meal of the day
is complete [ __ ] conspiracy
breakfast is literally the least
important meal this is the best meal
okay you might like i like this i like
the meal the breakfast meal i like but
you know it's really fun having it at
like midnight
yeah i mean i can't disagree with that
listen all these breakfasts i like
breakfast food
i hate like having to eat right when i
wake up it makes me nauseous yeah i
can't do it breakfast food is great
drunky food yes
the best okay listen drunk or breakfast
food is great
breakfast
is a [ __ ]
i only do it for the baby you hear me
i hear i eat breakfast now uh but
normally i would just be like coffee
after coffee like
that's my breakfast it's like
like an egg maybe a fruit a coffee it's
like you it's just [ __ ] banana
thanks i think it's a total conspiracy
by like the cereal company because you
just seen that on the commercials over
over like you got to eat a bowl of
cereal [ __ ] pieces of toast have a
glass of orange juice 10 ounces of milk
a [ __ ] slice of bacon
two pancakes 20 strawberries
no
cup of coffee you're done do a poll
they're also wanting the dinner poll
okay what's the problem
what time do you use the lunch pool
okay what time do you eat lunch or
dinner dinner
okay no
right lunch is settled
i just want to know if people agree that
breakfast is a [ __ ] meal again so
what am i doing that poor am i doing the
dinner no i don't have breakfast is
breakfast the most important meal of the
day yes or no the most important meal of
the day yes sir the most important meal
is clearly i would say dinner
dinner is everything
[ __ ] fried chicken
it's the most fun meal all right his
breakfast the most important meal of the
day and
the poll is up let's see
what's the people saying there's
something about going for breakfast on
the weekends yes breakfast on the
weekend hold
yes brunch will you go sit down you have
everybody loves brunch
go ahead
i'm just saying there's a there's
something about the vibe on the weekend
i agree yeah because you because you're
eating at lunchtime it's probably my
favorite meal yeah ever yeah you're
eating breakfast food at lunch because
you don't have to worry about work and
you're not forced to eat it when you
just woke up right well that's my
problem with breakfast by the way 77 73
are saying breakfast is not the most
important meal of the day thank you very
much my point is proven breakfast
conspiracy smashed wide open the truth
is out there okay
let's go
okay
let's go
all right let's do this wendy williams
judge mathis
okay
now this is a whole ass interview let me
just read this without breakfast there
would be no brunch that's true
breakfast crawled so brunch could walk
that's right
that's right
about right
alex jones ain't not a good dude who
skips breakfast i'll tell you that
all right sorry to the people who wanted
dinner paul i think we're moving on uh
guys
i don't care when you eat dinner
you know any i would say any time
between four and [ __ ]
one a.m is dinner yes but four is like
way too early way too early dinner needs
to be passed in my opinion five
yeah
even six i mean dinner at five and i
could have second dinner at 12.
you have second dinner
during yeah i mean when i'm out on my
diet pretty much yeah definitely
like two full meals no
um
i don't know but but easily yeah you
couldn't i mean let's be honest
[ __ ] it why not
you know
easily
if i there's my heart's content if i
didn't like
um let's say if i didn't censor myself
when it came to eating this would be my
perfect day okay
this is the disease that i have yeah
okay here you guys ha ha now i work at
chipotle too
this one actually i will say
this one i looked at and i said i didn't
remember taking this photo
this one's pretty wild
yeah
by some pure cosmic chance i'm not
actually making burritos and this could
this is easily my alternative universe
where i uh pizzaro never met ela
i'd be making chipotle burritos not that
there's anything wrong with it but it's
not exactly i'd be working at starbucks
you think so
you've been you'd have made it without
me
you definitely would have made it
without me
i don't know
here's another one what the [ __ ] is this
this one wait is that not me
i sent this to the i forgot where i've
seen this wait what is this
well the only reason i know it's not you
because you're not in shorts but
yeah that's the the only reason i would
say is you don't have this pants it
looks like an old photo of me in israel
it does but the hair too here and
everything yeah i sent that to our group
chat wait then where'd you get this it's
a mess i think sound on reddit maybe or
twitter i forget that's crazy
and dan's like why'd you just send a
picture of ethan
wait wait wait wait wow dude this one
that really really blew me away
zoom in you could argue and fool us i
feel like that it's a real photo
with this one it could be me that's what
i'm saying it could be me i don't know i
definitely don't own these pants yeah i
definitely owned this shirt well yeah i
definitely look egg the face is
identical even the
the way he's standing the posture well
the posture is a little unlike me
so out of character
no i don't talk i don't talk
also it looks like it does look like it
doesn't look like america
what's this writing here can you read
the writing what language it's in
um
does don't look like hebrew letters to
me but it's it's pretty blurry it's hard
to tell this is [ __ ] unbelievable man
maybe maybe it is
yeah so many doppelgangers
it's rabbi klein
i make the best chipotle burrito though
if i did work there
i'd be like [ __ ] scoop
scoop
big old scoops bro you know what i'm
saying
yeah like why be why where could
chipotle be
stingy
they're not though i you know some
people just don't put in the extra elbow
i know in general there but some people
just don't i actually
i feel like a lot of the times that i go
to chipotle they over stuff yeah
and that that's actually my issue or the
bowl
yeah i agree that
that's why i don't even get burritos
from there because it's like
it's stupid the way they make them yeah
but i think that
there's something wrong with their
burrito procedure there because like
well it gives everyone's diarrhea like
every other day so
there's definitely something wrong with
what they're doing over at chipotle
oh well that's why i shipped my pants
recently was because of chipotle was it
we had we had one recently it was really
good i didn't [ __ ] my pants i made it
clear it was so good
you had i told my recently in it in it
was it after the chipotle it may have
been that or some other mexican food we
got
i ate something really spicy
but when i was like and the guys were
like wait you show your pants i said no
i sharted and they're like oh well
that's different i said it is
completely different
apparently these guys walk around just
sharting all day
wait
it's when you fart and a little poop
sprays out that's what happened to you
yeah so they're saying that's normal
there's apparently that's normal
that sounds like they're like oh that's
totally
that sounds like [ __ ] in your pants i
agree
that's a ball right there is sharting
[ __ ] your pants they're
i think oh if you say yes yeah
i mean you could debate this but okay
how do you drop a whole load in your
pants like how does that happen i think
it depends on the amount of poop
anyways people are going to get mad at
me for talking about poop again
but i think it it depends on the amount
of poop that comes out of your sphincter
well i don't mean any amount at all is a
problem you're technically [ __ ] your
pants my friend
all right all right let's move on shall
we i just put up the pole okay well this
is important the ugliest sentence i've
ever read so wait what is the how is it
titled
is sharding [ __ ] your pants
okay good yes ninety percent say yeah
okay
you guys fed me some weird conspiracy
and a b don't be stay silent you are
you're co-signing zach
i just if you shart you [ __ ] your pants
yes i fully agree what
i mean
you know what you say that's not what
you said so he said monday
what do we have this discussion yes some
it was all my views have changed since
then
because
when do we have this conversation on the
show no no no no and i was like wait you
guys shark often no i said
you said it happened sometimes
no i've never said that i kind of find
it weird that you guys are so
comfortable talking about [ __ ] i just
said i'm [ __ ] shy i'm not gonna tell you
guys i'm sharding oh for [ __ ] sake
you okay whatever who cares
um let's talk about wendy williams and
judge mathis because speaking of
sharding
did you start
no wendy she's always [ __ ] starting
that's called a transition av
oh thanks zach you're always in the loop
about to transition these turds into the
toilet
love why are you defining shark for me
[Laughter]
means [ __ ] plus fart therefore therefore
transitive property
a shark
you are depositing [ __ ]
into your underwear
if there's poop in your pants you [ __ ]
yourself yes
but i think it depends on how much [ __ ]
no
i think it's the quantity of [ __ ]
that is called denial zack yeah
you're talking about like maybe
sometimes you fart and it's like just
one little drop of poop yeah that's what
i would define as sharding
that's weird if you just do a little
trip like a little misting of boop
i still think you shoot your pants
unfortunately
also you should get that checked out
definitely
nick akado probably
shares the issue with you
yeah that's that's it i don't know how
you keep the poop in that bottle i saw
that's a that's bad that's a bad [ __ ]
shutter right there
there's a video chris clemons has on his
youtube channel where he's just dyeing
his hair and he shits his pants like on
camera and he send it let me let me find
it who's chris clemons he's a youtuber
he's pretty funny
he was pregnant you gotta pee a lot
chris
chris clemons who is this
um
i don't recognize him
but i'll happily watch him [ __ ] his
pants
happily
yeah i mean
you know [ __ ] it
i pooped my pants
alrighty
um coming right up here we go everybody
here it is
dying my hair leopard print yeah i don't
think that's the uh the standout moment
from this video
oh my god i think i just like i can't
wait because it's not youtube
tits are out yeah no they're just
fashionable baby
wait hold on i know i need um no no no i
need higher resolution here
oh my god i kind of like it mostly
because it's not youtube funny tips are
out yeah no they're just
fashionable baby
the next clip contains content that is
triggering to only me please keep me in
your thoughts
oh my god i think i just like
i think i just liquid pooped my pants i
just look this is dude you touched it
that is
so funny
what the [ __ ] is
you can't write this that's interesting
because i thought that only happened to
guys that look like me and i mean he
looks healthier than me oh it can happen
to anyone
it's so embarrassing to be like
just we're so disgusting vile
[ __ ] and pissing and
semen stomping on feet and
nicocado's just got a gaping [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no way
carol baskin's dead husband
found alive in costa rica dude
this is huge
oh my god what the [ __ ] this is breaking
news
there's no way what i mean def said so
but the department of homeland
well yeah if you the second season just
came out there is some very interesting
stuff that was going on i'm looking into
it now but
it is it is definitely possible i can't
wait to watch it well okay because if
she for sure if they find evidence that
she didn't kill him yeah then she
deserves a big apology from the world oh
my god because everybody thought for
sure she fed him to the lion yes
everybody
the tigers whatever
wait scroll the scroll scroll i want to
see more
tiger king star carol baxton is glad to
hear ex-husband is apparently alive and
well
what the freak
is so crazy keep going however the last
season um
she wants the blah blah
oh there's a spoiler she's asking to be
removed from the she's suing them
because they sh because she's i think
she just wants money let's be honest
well they painted her as a murderer
well we're finding out that that didn't
happen well they kind of still they kind
of still are this season too oh
yeah
well then maybe she
can sue them
uh but hey [ __ ] it next
um i just found a nicoto pooping himself
compilation if you would like to see it
what i'll say for work is it
let me find out yeah
wow he's done it enough times for a
compilation that's pretty disturbing
they said that my husband don lewis is
alive and well in costa rica
[ __ ] did you not see everyone
talking about you
he was very comfortable with her taking
the fall for killing him which is an
interesting story in itself right
um but it sounds like this life
insurance fraud or something um
oh
well that would mean would that mean
they were in on it together because she
would be the beneficiary right not not
to spoil anything but the dude from what
they're saying was into some very
very shady [ __ ] what makes me think that
they may have been in on it together is
because his will was written very weird
where
it was altered to
be not after death but missing so even
if you went missing she would inherit
that so that is an interesting detail if
she got a fat life insurance policy then
i would definitely look at you carol yep
because i've seen enough datelines to
know that whoever's getting that life
insurance policy is probably the main
suspect yes that's like fifty percent of
the deadline
if this is true joe's just gonna go
ballistic
he's still gonna go after her though i
can't wait for those hot like tracks
he's going to drop
he's going to drop something is he still
in prison
yeah shout out yeah
shout outs
but the guy who was saying that joe is
paying him to commit the murder is now
saying he's now taking it back and he's
saying he's willing to admit to lying
under perjury
god that's so interesting what if joe
was framed
definitely seem like
we gotta watch season two elo there's
like is it good so far it's worth
watching it it is very it's short it's
five episodes
it's it's good though it's very good
okay
all right can we get to this [ __ ]
wendy williams thing
christ's sake
okay so what's your review of the
[ __ ] compilation olivia i mean it is
safe for work except for in the first
video at two minutes 33 seconds
he shows the chair
[Laughter]
he shows his own [ __ ] in a youtube video
that is vile that is unforgivable
let's just watch a brit i'm not going to
show that let's just watch like
how can you show your own [ __ ] on
youtube that seems like a tos
you show me yeah yeah didn't we get um
we got a video removed and it was not
even real yeah it was a sketch back in
the day i did a sketch with poop and it
was like obviously just chocolate
and they removed it we did like
yeah yeah i think i got a strike
was the eat your own [ __ ] challenge yeah
it was a parody about like all the
challenges i [ __ ] it or something i
don't remember
did you send me the image
okay let's see
you you disgusting freak look at this
either
i hate this look at this
oh here yeah
oh i hate it disgusting
i don't want i i i don't know if i can
interview a guy who shows this [ __ ] on
youtube
nothing came out
is he trying to [ __ ] himself
i don't think so
close it keep it closed
oh
it almost feels like he's driving
because
yeah i'm squeezing oh
he's going through the bathroom right
he's doing stick
i mean when you eat like this it's
pretty much assumed that
what's crazy to me is like the kind of
p word he does
and his diet has got to be a bad combo
dude
like because he does all the gaping
stuff and with that diet man that has
got to be a wretched combo
i was gonna say i could see it slipping
oh for sure uncontrollably all right
it's just
it's probably gotta be a part of the
maybe
yeah there's gotta be some scat fetish
element to it because i thought that
wasn't isn't that not allowed on only
fans
oh i don't know actually no
yeah i think we did talk about that one
point that's like one of the
terms like accidental
um
i don't know i might have the answer for
you
because you know
all right let's wendy wins with judge
matthews
so
anyway here here they had this explosive
interview
she calls him out for cheating and then
he calls her a crackhead apparently he
destroys her in this whole heated
conversation
here it is you know i think we should
just watch the whole damn thing
i think
she came on his show to promote
something
i don't know is this the beginning of
the bid yeah yeah uh uh what happened
was when she picked the red card i
showed her i said you know more about
the streets than me now i'm off the
streets and you're in it because she was
right and i was wrong with the
three-card if i had some cards i would
ask you to do that too i don't feel as
if there's anything wrong with that
judge because you know why
well let's look at this i want to talk
with you because here on this show
whether it's tv or radio one thing that
wendy williams does is keep it real with
our audience now my audience knows all
about me and what i've been through and
what they don't know i go into explicit
details in my book
now that might not be true according to
you about this woman that you that okay
so what sounds like wendy's starting
[ __ ] she's like i'm real unlike you
and then i think judge mathis brings the
gavel down well it sounds to me like
she's defending herself though like he
was calling her not real
it could be i don't have the the word
where i don't have anything before this
and allegedly you slept with you
allegedly got her pregnant
just
and then you fill in the meat wendy i
didn't read that part now you make it
now okay let me draw and wbls about to
be sued for defamation you gonna make
some stuff okay judge you aren't
all right it's called defamation when
okay you did not allege that all right
i'll tell you what she alleged it wasn't
that all right you tell me what she
allows judge in all of your life i'm not
angry yes you are yes you are i'm not
angry she said that she had had an
encounter with me where i was getting
high during cocaine
brought to you by
classic what the hell is that brother
you feel addicted to based on your oh
it's like an audio jungle thing
yo this is a good conversation she's
like yeah you were doing a cocaine i was
like excuse me wendy like you've never
heard of cocaine just to be clear she
did start it this is her first
interactions when i'm seeing that he
went on to promote his book
and instead of asking about his book she
started asking him about his affair
so in true wendy williams style
she's a [ __ ] starter she's crossed the
line so many times and uh judge mathis
brings duh he
on can you not what the [ __ ]
i'm saying i'm trying to listen to this
[ __ ]
all right let's start let's just go to
your jungle mentally prepare ourselves
we're starting now your nasal passages
and all these days you're missing at
work
[Music]
i've never used cocaine in my life okay
never okay tell me what else she likes
she also alleged uh uh
um
that that i actually sleep with my wife
yes she is yeah yeah
right and so
and if you want to believe that
ridiculous nonsense you feel free to
and you want to keep fueling it when no
one else has even asked me about nobody
else
everyone in the media oh she's asking to
get bombed on nobody keeps it real like
me
hmm judge math is about to go off
by the way he's like you want to talk
about cocaine your nose passage is
[ __ ] up you're coming in and out of
the bathroom
like okay judge your mouth let's go
knows that tabloids print trash but
every week that they pay people to come
up with you or anyone in this studio
tabloid and tell them i want to sell you
a story on someone and they'll buy it
right and if that's the type of stuff
that you fuel on your show
never met her never use cocaine now
let's talk about fueling your stuff you
on the other hand have admitted to being
addicted to coke absolutely secondly you
continue to show symptoms of your
addiction okay lastly
symptoms coming these nasal passages you
keep gas coughing up and i did afraid
he came here ready though for war
well okay so let's just remember here
this is real [ __ ] though
this is
yeah
what what led to this conversation okay
so apparently what abe learned yeah is
that he came on to promote a book yeah
and okay and instead of asking him about
the book she ended up she started asking
about this affair okay or this crazy
story that and he's like okay so now
they're both on a radio show he's on her
radio show oh this is that interview
this is that this is the end okay yeah
yeah oh so her show was on the radio
yeah yeah yeah
this is 2003. okay this is a long time
and she's done this to a lot of other
people like uh diddy and uh
houston yeah trying to call them out
rent winnie houston went off on her as
well by the way her most famous [ __ ] up
was outing method man's wife as having
cancer he was trying to keep it a secret
and she knew and she like outed his wife
and it was like just a [ __ ] he was like
it was really disgusting
that's messed up is that what happened
maybe i see you typing you correct me
i'm just yeah
just double checking yeah no actually
there's a clip of him talking about her
which is really good if you guys have
that
but what's interesting to me is judge
mathis came here for war because he's
like okay girl i actually have the whole
dossier on your ass
blame your child for your
addiction
lastly
lastly your bisexual activity i'll show
your
audience want to know about who's
yelling in the back that's what i was
wondering who's the like order in the
court
i think she's got some
people in there who are loving this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
her own cast is turning on her
that's like dan going oh
oh you just got [ __ ] phone
getting her getting killed and dana's
like spitting out cheering me them on tv
i'll show you i always want to know
about that and i've heard that rumor i'm
sure
yeah yeah oh he watches does he watch
when you do it yes don't you know no i
don't know i didn't know nothing wrong
with that yeah it's all consensual
everyone's happy judge about this you're
that low down
lastly
lastly we can continue with what i heard
about all those abortions like eight you
had eight right
eight
that's a lot if it's true but obviously
this judge matthews
that's the rumor now you want to keep
fueling that do you did you write about
that in your book i wrote about abortion
in my book
this radio show knowing that you had
eight abortions a cocaine addict and a
bisexual my god
sponsors continue to put up money for
this show
okay well judge mathis is doing a little
bit of a
moral arbiter yeah there's nothing wrong
with
being a bisexual or doing drugs it's a
little bit hard getting an embarrassment
yeah i mean eight abortions it is weird
loosey-goosey with that but i don't know
if he's right about the number
yeah what what olivia i just like that
part made me mad everything else or
the
homophobia and the abortion thing is
just it's totally
yeah also she like wrote about it in her
book also i mean he's like saying that
she's addicted but she's saying that
she's she didn't hide that so yeah
that's true
yeah i guess wendy well yeah the heat
kind of not looking great here it's a
mud it's a mud slinging war just saying
just saying
i mean that's what you get when you go
on wendy williams i guess
these guys are both pretty trashy let's
be honest
eight abortions though
i mean like first of all i'm i'm one i'm
pro
you know
it is weird for sure yeah
but do we know that's true yeah but just
assuming that someone's got eight
abortions we need maybe something there
we need to have a conversation about it
yeah about protection
yeah if you've ever wanted to kill
somebody
i think i think i know who she's wanted
to kill
judge mathis you know what charles
abortion crowd i can tell you that let
me just say watch out for them
you better say something to them
streets of america and if you think
you're going to send me back to the
streets fueling these nonsensical rumors
that come out
by the way i gotta respect the man who
can
rise up
become an actual judge
get his pass the bar be a practicing
lawyer and still keep that street
you know what i'm saying it's pretty
wild combo yeah i don't know how it goes
together that's crazy
that's why you got a show man he's one
of a kind by the way here's method man
uh talking about how
um
just a little aside in 2006 wendy
williams revealed on her show
that methman's wife tamika smith have
been diagnosed with cancer despite the
fact that the rapper and his wife
wanting to keep that information private
uh you were going through something with
uh
with your wife like i think she was sick
or something like that right yeah she
was sick
is she alright now i'd like to thank
wendy williams for bringing that to the
masses because she didn't have to go on
the radio and say that [ __ ]
i like to keep stuff like that private
but yeah she was sick but everything's
all right now
all right better than what it was well
then that's what started it that's what
it was that's what's up man i know a lot
of us go through it you know he's
feeling like yo that ain't nobody
[ __ ] business right there though
that's i'm sorry that's just how i feel
about it and [ __ ] that's her business
she didn't want anybody to know about it
you know what i'm saying and i respected
her wishes right there so for the media
to bring that and put that [ __ ] out
there like that i think that [ __ ] is mad
tacky and disrespectful
yeah well you know we won't even run
that man so don't worry no y'all can run
that i want that to be i want that to be
ran i'm talking about as far as the way
it was done in the beginning because
she's she's past all that now but when
okay it was going on and all that and
people it was done by mcgee wendy
williams did it all right her she's the
one that did it you can attack me any
way you want to i'm in the entertainment
business but you don't attack my family
man my wife ain't nothing do it that man
had all nothing to do with that you did
not have to do that her family members
didn't even know she was sick
that's [ __ ] up we still live in our
same community where we used to live at
the people that lived around them didn't
know she was sick t you said that [ __ ]
everybody looking at her staring at her
you know how comfortable that makes
somebody feel especially somebody that's
going through chemo stupid ass [ __ ]
bad enough she didn't have her hair on
her head you think she wants people
staring at her pointing at her talking
about how sick she is
nobody knew anything until wendy
williams said that [ __ ]
she hasn't won a lot of fans man she
doesn't have any fans and the people
that i listen to are just as [ __ ]
dumb
a [ __ ] idiot man like she can say
whatever she wants to say about me i
never call up there for [ __ ] she can say
whatever she want to say
but you don't attack my [ __ ] family
man you got to be out your [ __ ] mind
lady
for real you gotta be at your
[ __ ] mind man ain't no regular
okie doke [ __ ] man ain't no insane
justin timberlake ass [ __ ] man
come from park hill staten island park
hill [ __ ]
you've been on my block you know where
you know where i'm from you been on my
block these [ __ ] little [ __ ] around
there think i don't know sniffing blows
sucking these [ __ ] off and [ __ ] i know
however you want to do it wendy but me
i'm not going to do it verbally i'm not
going to come on your little show and
try and bark on you and [ __ ] like that
now man i'm street [ __ ] you see me
[Laughter]
i mean respect for standing up to his
wife so
this beef is still going on
she did an interview in january of this
year wendy where she claims to have a
one night stand with method man
method's wife is going back and forth
with her saying that she's still
dragging this out for years
wendy's vile i hate her oh the happy
ending can't uh i got updated that his
wife is cancer-free
but can you imagine that is good news
yeah can you imagine that nobody knows
you have even your own family no that's
you that's real messed up actually i
find it touching how much he yeah cares
about his wife's struggle and he respect
her privacy i mean
to go through chemo that's like the
worst thing that
anybody she's so vile she's she's so
vile
if you guys think that i like her or
something just make that clear i've
always thought she's a vile [ __ ]
freak that's why we like to talk about
her when i was locked away at a place
that i didn't belong because i'm not an
addict i was addicted to coke and i quit
on my own wait you just said you're not
an african then you said you're addicted
the
coke also later in this i've linked a
video where she says that she's been
living for a long time in a in
essentially a halfway she's like listen
i'm not an addict i'm a i'm just
addicted to coke and live in a sober
living house she was like i got cleaned
by myself even though i live with a
bunch of other sober people who help me
stay clean yeah yeah nothing wrong with
me
baseball girl by myself that was
something else i wanted to talk about
but go ahead you
know i smoked a blunt with red man
excuse me with method man
um
um
while i gave him a bath and it was a
one-night stand and what
yeah you look how she throws that out
like that yeah all of a sudden years
later she dropping that she's giving him
a bath i'm sorry who that's not
let me give you a bath
nobody can do it
especially on a one-night stand i just
find that odd the way she dropped it
seemed really made up too
she knows what she's doing she's trying
to promote something i forget what was
coming out i
think he was like a biopic or something
even the guy's like nah get out of here
but like you did the guy so dirty and
you really gonna try to drag him and his
wife again because you're accusing him
of infidelity
and he'll deny it maybe not you know
that wasn't in the movie i it wasn't in
the movie it wasn't in the movie because
red man excuse me method man is still
very angry at me
i don't know for for being me for
telling the truth it was one night we
were in the club a fight broke out and
gunshots broke out
the the fight was ridiculous the whole
wu-tang was there but it was only meth
yeah i'm sure the whole boutain was
there there was there was bullets
blowing i took them home gave them a
bath
she should have known better
lutang ain't nothing to [ __ ] with hell
no [ __ ] up
by the way that was pretty cold his
message to her was pretty icy
who wants to watch wendy williams the
movie
lifetime movie straight to lifetime
let's go i'd actually i would actually
watch that for the memes not me but one
of you guys watching and tell me if it's
pulled i'd watch that in my eye i mean
one of you watching give me a summary
yeah one of you guys watch it and pull
the highlights
let's continue because this is pretty
this is good [ __ ] right yeah yeah
exactly
we're about 20 years late on the beef
but
yeah it makes sense
this yeah this aged ripe sounds good so
this happened recently this whole thing
with about
earlier this year yeah
methods
wife responded
in february
so
wow
what a violation she is man
but this thing that we're watching
people are saying is from like 2000
2004. yeah this this is ancient beef
but it's new i mean like i'm a wendy
william historian so this is new to me
you know i want to go see if wendy like
how her movie is reviewed
it's actually bizarre there's
no reviews because it's not a real movie
some [ __ ] well hold on did it come
out yet yeah
you think so i could check imdb that's
that's the
if it has like 800 ratings you know
nobody watched it
yeah that's honestly not that i mean
obviously that's not good but it
couldn't be worse well i'm sure it's the
middle of the road spam it's only 500 uh
only 500 votes yeah that's that's
basically like a a student film i'll
watch it i was going to say i yeah i can
watch it if you want i'm kind of i used
to love it yeah i used to love to watch
shitty lifetime movies with lena's mom
so but you know that like she
she's made a film about her own life
right of course she's gonna be like
just can you imagine you're not supposed
to make uh your own biopic you promise
it's biopixels
[Laughter]
jackson jumped on a preacher in l.a you
didn't see that now i'm just too fixated
on drugs and sex to discuss this
is that your problem you got a real
fixation with drugs and sex and that's
all you talk about from what i
understand on your show and now we know
that why you had
what church do you go to judge mathis i
mean i don't believe i don't i don't
agree with his uh
his philosophy on morals but it is funny
girl you need jesus
someone said uh one of the mega awesome
nerds said shout out oh he watched it i
watched it don't waste your time it's
not funny bad it's just bad bad
that's that's important that's the fear
that's the thing yeah but thanks for
letting us know
you probably just saved a lot of people
a lot of times that's good so skip that
movie you need god in your life
not man anyone that knows my show know
that i don't take any disrespect or i
don't let anybody say anything they want
to me without me checking the real
strong and real tough and that's what
you get in the day wendy you're getting
a real good checking all right which is
what you need and quite frankly that's
overdue you get your folks on your show
and you just think you can just
steamroll
first of all she's getting bodied and i
think they're trying to play him off i
just heard music
yeah she got she think i should say yeah
she doesn't defend herself
like at all
you'll see she just goes okay let's
let's take some calls interesting i love
that the area where he was a judge in
detroit it was the worst crimes he's
heard everything he's dealt with he's
the worst yeah he knows
he's a real street boy
you can say
anything to know well that's what i do
on my show
it's actually very comical to me
all of the all of the protesting you're
doing it's almost like you know that
saying that's just
too much being checked
you understand me clearly this is called
when you think that you can just treat
people unfairly and say what you want i
am not saying what i want to you i i i
simply ask you about
i immediately told you
that it was untrue and i told you that
it was tabloid trash which all public
figures have to do with bro with the
damn
is it actually very long i don't know if
yeah anything good uh
you've i think you get the idea well at
one point he goes he says like you just
returned from the bathroom i think i see
cocaine on your nose
and she's like
no comment yeah and she she's just like
let's take someone in the chat is saying
they hope we know that she has been in
the hospital and is in the hospital i
guess for months fighting for her life
right now
no we did i don't know about that she's
fighting for her life right now i didn't
know she was fighting for yeah we talked
about on the show that she was
hospitalized a while ago i didn't know
if she was like dying i did see that uh
there's other people doing her show
right now
oh yeah she uh with whitney coming yeah
she did like a whole week i was like
sick i like this show way better
she was released from the hospital late
september she i don't know if she went
back i'm looking though
come on
who what the wendy sims out here in the
chat being like
us just for like the sound bite remember
that yes that happened they claimed to
whoop they claimed the whoop whoops um
november 11th it said williams announced
that she has been diagnosed with graves
disease an autoimmune disorder that
causes an overactive thyroid three years
ago she has previously taken extended
breaks from her show and she's taking
one now yeah as i say it's yeah we knew
she had graves yeah
look she's the uh you know what am i
supposed to do if she's like
okay let's have a serious conversation
someone's a douche
they live their whole life let's take
rush limbaugh as an example vile [ __ ]
evil dude [ __ ] bag one of the biggest
pieces of [ __ ] to ever live
exactly so he's dying of cancer what am
i supposed to pretend like i like him
i mean
no you know
some people even say they're glad he's
dead
i think they just uh wanted us to be
aware
yeah that's fair no but this this is
actually a
conversation that i'm i'm curious about
yeah
you know
what do you think i think wendy doesn't
show the same empathy when she talks
about people who died or are dying she
wishes
how about the one tick tocker guy yeah
she goes uh look at this little [ __ ]
guy he has less followers he has more
frozen me well i have more instagram
anyway just look at this weirdo anyway
he died
he was murdered yeah well anyway he was
murdered
you know i mean what about that one it's
like
if she's dying is completely
incidental to the it has nothing to do
with this conversation yeah it's just a
matter of like uh
timing like
if she's literally dying right now maybe
not the best timing watch this and then
tell me [ __ ] i thought
he's 19.
and he was murdered
monday oh this morning yeah i know i i'm
i apologize this is just they show the
whole thing but i'm trying to find
whatever you guys remember yeah
death to all of them
she lived by the she lived by she died
you know what i'm saying or she live
yeah live or die by it yeah
but i don't think she's dying for the
record it doesn't sound like anyone said
that
publicly at least i don't know well how
long we've been going by the way long
time three hours
where's the food here yeah where's my
parm sandwich is my parm sandwich here
where's my parmesan where's my parm
sandwich i'm not sharing my sandwich
with you dan goes i didn't order
anything
five minutes man
cam is at begging for my meatball you
can't have food cam we've told you
some [ __ ] time you can't have my bean
actually
i have no passion for
a meatball by itself
it could be multiple in fact
i just i'll be honest uh-oh love
cover
not a fan of the meatball
oh you've never had swedish meatballs
it's really good it's really good
we've i remember having really good ones
in new york i think it's just part of
the pasta aesthetic where i'm just not
into pasta oh god
insane your worst personality trait is
your pasta
insane i've had any swedish meatballs i
used to work with a lot of sweets
[ __ ] do the godfather voice
you know what i just realized
with your anti-italian bigotry it is
totally
totally improper for you to be doing
food it's about character it's about the
territory
it's about not betraying your family dan
you come out here saying i can't do the
godfather voice who are you to come to
me after everything i've done for
you this is so problematic what you're
doing right now don't come to me you say
what italians just about meatballs
what are you tell your phobia you're
dahlia phobic
i'm sorry i wasn't paying attention let
me let me guess nexus jews is about
matzah
this man he knows nothing about our
culture about our food
i'll tell you what dad come take a
come take a ride on me out on the lake
i'll teach you a little something
did you say take a ride on you
i said take a ride out on the lake
i'll teach you a little something about
family
[Music]
and i come before you
the man accused me of not liking italian
food
then how come i eat pizza every [ __ ]
day
this guy
you broke my arm you broke my heart
where would we be without men
men who make pizzas
and impossible degrees in the oven
the oven kitchen reaching 120 to 130
degrees then made a pole
what's the pull
and should an italian phobe like ethan
be allowed to do the godfather voice oh
and the nose sorry
one piece of food a meatball shame on
you ooh
you would define the entire country by
one piece of media one character in a
piece
i'm just doing an impression of the
godfather
you literally put that what's the result
then dan you hate pasta you hate
meatballs
well mom
[Laughter]
it looks like the yeses are edging out
anyway so i guess you can proceed with
the gov
dan you try to step tonight
i'm the head of this family
[Music]
and you
my son
what have i done to deserve this
i brought you into this world into this
life i've given you everything
and you stand before me you're talking
to me yes
we're like the same age
you did not bring me into this world
i'll be listening to this officer maybe
immediately
please let me be your son
be a colder brother accusing me of
italian phobia
why don't you take a ride on the lake
[Music]
with such disrespect
what did i do to deserve this disrespect
on the day
of my wife's letting me order
a gpail
i got it like the day of my wife's of my
daughter's notice
it's a special day
the day that my wife lets me order a
cheat meal you come to me
with such disrespect
that chair you sit in who bought you
that chair then who bought you that
chair
um
exactly speech
[ __ ]
i'll tell you
i got a meatball right here for you
and it happens to be blotchy and red
from a rash
but let's not include that detail
[Music]
all right enough
what are we gonna do without meatballs
have you seen these chefs in the italian
kitchens it's hot impossibly hot
they're doing impossible things
they're taking pepperoni they're putting
it on
they're putting it on dough
they put it in the oven do you know how
dangerous
women couldn't do that where would we be
without men
you ever seen a woman cook a pie that's
outrageous
women don't know how to cook a pizza
it's crickets just total [ __ ]
crickets dude
that was brutal
yeah so eli just wants to go home says
the chat
it gets hard for me to sit here right
well i'm just waiting for the pizza to
run i'm just trying to give people a
little extra entertainment
it's sorry it's weird to see you guys
sitting in opposite
sitting positions because usually it's
my back pain let's just wrap it up then
just call it a day
guys thanks for watching at that bottom
i want to remind you
leftovers is coming out this sunday
cheers
cheers
special episode how to um communicate
with your
psycho conservative family that's right
which i must praise your um
your
ethan played the role of the role played
as the uh as uncle hank i think is the
name that we landed on yeah it was good
i i was very entertained by the thing
and there was a point where i think i
even stumped hassan like he's like oh
that was the best part it was like [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] rolling me dude
it was such a good app
yeah that's a good one
i like uh
i like uh
being white trash my brain don't hurt so
much
[Laughter]
don't hurt when i think
everybody's spamming channel five um
that's an h3tv thing we'll watch that
yeah we'll watch it on monday
um
one more reminder looney tunes teddy
fresh
it's all happening
teddyfish.com
it's all here go check it out
um
members bts is coming up it's a good one
too so thank you all members
love you
and we'll be back for monday next week
is thanksgiving so i don't think we have
a leftovers what we're doing three
episodes right dan
right yeah because we normally record
leftovers on thursdays what is what day
is thanksgiving it's on thursday
and leftovers was gonna be on that's
when filming that's where we normally
don't think yeah
but there's going to be an after dark or
is it yes
black friday after dark yeah
yeah we'll still do it you can skip it
if you want no i was just wondering if
because sometimes people have to go to
their families and stuff it's the day
after thanksgiving i mean
i'll be here i'll be here my family
lives in town anyways so it's not a
it's a one day thing for me
okay
we're here we we have a duty to the
people yes we do
the people want any reason to uh
distract them from their families
and that's the service we provide
oh now you're
there we go now we're ready all right
let's i got up me i got a parmesan
sandwich with my name all over it hello
have a great weekend we'll see you on
monday
you're listening to the hp podcast what
we got on the scene could it be papa
shoe nights for bill delfin we're
talking
what you gonna do with me then love and
the whole damn crew goose and gaps with
all the guests you'll see the best
podcasts in the world take it from me jc
over cherry xp baby we podcast now
you're watching h 2 3 3 3 3